We are live.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for tuning into the
podcast.
Once again,
my friend Brian Redman,
of course,
as always,
and today joining us the wonderful and
talented Mr Dane Cook.
Talk Joke.
Chris,
before we get going to take our sponsor,
the fleshlight,
have you ever used one of these things?
I fucked with.
I have not filled.
That is fantastic.
Oh my God.
Oh Brian,
that's our delay in the background.
You guys can't hear it,
but my,
uh,
my computer's a volume was on of course,
but this is a sponsor of our show is
supposed to.
There's a little button right in the
middle.
Brian.
Upper level around background thing.
Upper level.
Is it off?
Okay.
Yeah,
it looks like it's tough.
Powerful.
Anyway,
the idea,
the idea first of all,
why the.
Well they offered to sponsor the show
and I said why not,
you know,
middle.
But why in the shape of the flash light?
Why is,
why is it a flashlight?
I guess that's it.
So it makes it easier to hold so you can
fuck it easier.
Okay.
And then once you're,
once you're done and you ejaculate,
can you open that?
Yeah,
that's what I say.
Yeah.
You unscrew the bottom and released the
crack.
It just slithers out no into the sink.
It's like something else that it is more
shameful for some reason than
masturbating.
It feels way better,
but it's more shameful.
Like,
like I always joke that as I'm coming,
I'm regretting it as I'm coming on this.
It also serve as a flashlight.
It doesn't light up and cases,
not a flashlight should have a little
laser pointer or something like that.
Yeah.
It's just a silly little piece of shit
talking about flesh.
That's awesome.
If you want pink and last night you
performed for pink.
Kind of a fucking shitty segway.
Was that asshole.
How dare you subjected my ears to that.
How was that though?
Is that
pretty cool?
She called me up and she asked me if I
would do her a birthday party for her
boyfriend,
a carey heart,
you know,
the BMX guy and all that and I haven't
done a private anything in forever.
And I was like,
Nah,
I don't know.
I'm a fan and stuff,
but it seems weird,
right?
I was like,
I can't do that.
And then she was like,
well,
this is what,
you know,
how much I can pay.
And I was like a,
it was actually a few weeks ago when the
deal came together.
I was like,
if you,
if you can do that and get me a court
side for Lakers,
Celtics,
which I thought was impossible.
I'm like,
I'm never going to get courtside last
minute for the series.
And she called back.
She goes,
I got court side for the last two games
and I'll,
I'll give you the,
uh,
the big that you want.
Holy Shit.
Next thing into homesteading there.
It was like,
it was,
it was the highest paying hell Gig I've
ever done.
It was bizarre.
It was a completely bizarre.
It was weird.
How many people were there?
A 75 and they had a pink and Carrie was
on stage and like thrones that she'd
gotten him.
And will you,
will you hired?
Do your
totally.
Just talk to them and just say hi,
fuck around.
Pretty much could have done anything,
but I knew they were fans of like,
you know,
my comedy,
so I was like,
all right,
I want to go in and do well,
but by the time I got up there
everybody's shit phase.
And it felt like the Boston or something
back in New York at like two in the
morning.
Yeah.
Pink lately.
Have you.
This thing is like recent shows.
Yeah.
No,
she's,
she's an incredible performer.
Yeah.
I wrote a whole blog about her.
Brian,
why am I not hearing myself?
There we go.
It's just that it was just that.
Just the vine for you.
Yeah,
dude,
uh,
I wrote a whole blog about her
performance at the emmy's that I watched
and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like it was like perfect.
A voice was perfect.
The way she carried herself was perfect.
And then when she actually suspended
herself and started spinning around like
there's no fucking way.
She's really this good and she's really
sick.
Yeah.
Really singing the whole time.
And even people on the radio were like,
she was limp sanken.
I don't think she was.
I don't think so.
She wasn't,
she wasn't doing that and seeing anyways
as ridiculous if she really was doing.
She just fell doing that shit.
Yeah,
I saw that video.
yeah,
yeah.
Scariest.
We fell,
but when she fell for wire,
pulled her and pulled it to the very end
til it was taught and I thought if that
snapped,
it could have cut her head off.
Totally.
And then it would have been the most
popular video on how crazy would that
have been?
Could you imagine watching pink get her
head cut off?
Capitated.
But you imagine if that was a real viral
video.
Wow.
And then the sales would go up because
isn't everything posthumous like.
Yeah.
Giant.
Huge,
huge.
Yeah.
Anytime you die,
even if you were mediocre when you die,
you were a little bit better than
mediocre.
Yeah.
Everybody loves you.
Everybody goes crazy.
Then they're going to hear you again.
So they go nuts.
Buy Your Shit.
Even though they forgot about you.
Look at Michael Jackson,
who's,
by the way,
incredibly brilliant,
talented,
but after he died,
man,
everybody went fucking nuts.
Everybody went nuts to buy shit.
I thought it was fake for a bit
actually.
Yeah.
Because I'm Kinda like,
I'm always like,
all right,
these guys,
she theorist a little bit,
man.
It's like I thought that,
you know,
he'd pop out like six months later
because he needed something.
He needed the love back man.
There was a lot of people that were not
feeling Michael Jackson for a long time.
I don't think anybody's ever even tried
to pull that death off.
I think if you tried to die and I think
that's a federal crime,
I think if you visit really.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I don't think you're allowed to do that,
you know?
I mean even as a publicity stunt,
you would have to have medical records
and if you have medical records and
people are going to find out they don't
exist.
If you're faking it.
True.
I don't think he can do it.
The whole Tupac thing.
It's ridiculous how it's gotten that
Elvis too,
man.
So all Elvis back then.
Maybe you could pull it off.
You know,
they killed JFK.
They could probably fuck elvis up.
Well,
that was the whole thing is that
everybody said Elvis faked his death to
get away from the colonel to live a
normal life because the colonel was like
this megalomaniac.
Isn't that hilarious that people are so
romantic,
they don't realize that when you get to
be Elvis famous,
you are guaranteed fucking insane.
Yeah.
There's no way you can get away from it.
Elvis,
this is back before the Internet is
back.
You know,
I mean terrible movies.
It was doing.
He couldn't even leave his house,
couldn't even walk down the street.
When people would see him,
they would start screaming and fall to
their knees.
Yeah.
My favorite Elvis story that I heard was
at the height of everybody loving and
hating Elvis.
Those buttons came out.
You know,
I love Elvis,
and then the I hate Elvis.
Pins came out.
He made those.
The colonel came up with that.
They sold more.
I hate Elvis pins.
I've heard of a bunch of people doing
that or stealing that exact same idea.
That's awesome that it's so awesome.
You know Elvis thing must be so sucky.
If you were a dude back then,
how the fuck do you compete with Elvis?
Your girl is screaming and yelling and
you're fucking her and you know,
she really would way rather be fucking
Alvin.
All you can really do is just play into
it and just tell her you love Elvis and
take her to elvis and like just try to
make her elvis fantasy come to fruition.
Yeah,
put on the fucking wig.
The whole deal.
Mutton chops.
It was elvis,
an elvis clip when he was really.
He was really fucked up.
He was doing whatever drugs he was doing
and he was bored and he was not
remembering the lyrics and there's a Gig
he was doing in Hawaii where he so
fucking bored and you watch this.
He's not singing any of the lyrics,
varieties just inside jokes with his
band members and then he does the thing.
Re slowly backs up slowly during this
one song to his three backup singers and
in the middle of the park he just turns
and screams in their faces and scares
the shit out of them.
Like literally turns.
It goes and they're all like,
as they're trying to sing,
he was gone.
He was gone.
He was way too big.
You can't get that big.
It's not,
it's not safe,
vague.
And he was like,
so I,
I mean I,
I'm kind of a huge elvis fan and there's
one documentary that Priscilla actually
did years ago based on what she wrote
where she finally talked about how
insecure he really wasn't,
you know,
he had his buddies like living with them
and shit and if they wanted to go out to
a dinner and he was by himself and he
would freak out,
he would shoot TV's up.
He had to have his friends around him.
Twenty four slash seven.
Wow.
Joe,
you kind of have that whole entourage.
You want a gang of this?
Have you joe,
you like,
we used to like always roll with huge
groups of people.
You can't too problematic,
but you prefer that kind of.
Well,
it's,
it's always more fun to have a bunch of
guys that you're friends with that like
go to you and gigs,
but if you have too many and you have to
manage them all,
then it becomes a pain in the ass.
It becomes more of a pain in the ass
with getting my friends to get
downstairs in time so we can get to the
fucking show and you know,
did you call this God's wake them up,
we got to go to the fucking airport,
where is he?
And there's five different guys and have
got their own bullshit and then dude
start arguing with each other and then
it became ugly.
Gonna become like,
okay,
this is nonsense.
So I had to cut it.
Most of it.
It was like a reality show for awhile.
It was,
it was too much though.
It was too much like that.
It was,
there was too many people,
you know,
when it was taped and Eddie and me and
you and Larry and Mike Young and all
these other dudes and we'd all go out.
I mean,
come on.
That was ridiculous with a giant group
on the road,
man.
Do you want.
Do you like to run with a bunch of
dudes?
You always taught it with your friends?
I kind of,
I pretty much have stuck close with the
same guys that I started,
like my graduating class,
bobby Kelly Bell,
Benny,
you know,
our new bur when I first started and
patrice,
because we kind of came up like a little
bit after you like you were a couple of
years ahead,
headlining around.
I did a bunch of really a fun little
gigs for Dick already.
The comedy hots.
Remember those comedy gods?
Yeah.
The Cambridge did.
We did Victoria's comedy hunting
monkeys.
Dane was with uh,
a comedy troupe with Bob Kelly and him
and Benny was so,
it was a good comedy troupe.
You guys were funny.
It was good.
You know,
it was interesting.
You would do comedy sketches and then
you would do like each guy would go up
and do stand up.
Right.
And so we would work together.
Do these addict already gigs.
Those were fucking fun.
Our sketch comedy Improv group was,
was so bad.
We were so bad at Improv and everybody,
you know,
the first rule of Improv is don't deny,
but we were so bad at Improv that our
first roles was denied,
so we were just command and completely
ruined scenes by like you're pretending
pantomiming I'm holding a baby and you
can be dude,
why are you holding a tire?
It would just fall apart from there,
but we just had a ball.
You guys had some good ones.
You had some good sketches.
It was fun.
I mean it was,
it was experimental.
It was like you guys are taking chances
who were doing something a little
unusual at a comedy club just when you
were doing comedy too.
Yeah,
that was probably actually better for us
opening with our standup and then we'd
just go fuck around and do music or
skits or Improv or whatever for,
you know,
whatever.
The rest of the hour to fill it up.
Still ever tried to do improv and once
in a while or do you just only stand up
now?
I'm a little bit.
I've been bringing al because Al has
been hosting down at the laugh factory
and I'll bring it up once in a while and
we'll do stuff at the very end just to,
you know,
whatever a skit or dumb and I will do
some stuff once in a while where I'll
just bring them up and bad some stuff
around but not like I used to not like,
you know,
sketch full on sketch upright citizens
brigade.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm not a sketch guy.
I really rather prefer watching standup.
I mean sketches are fun and everything
like that.
But just remember that movie you did,
that little short movie did for Kelly
Kirsten where you're talking about the
cable bill and stuff like that.
It's like a five minute clip or
something like that.
I just pretended to be my dad.
It was really easy.
How did it go from.
I've always wanted to know because you
were in Boston and you're the first guy
who we watched go from,
you know,
headlining to then you're on tv man,
and it was like everybody was looking at
you going how to,
how do I do that?
What,
like,
how did you turn the corner?
$100 total luck.
Complete.
Total luck.
I uh,
was uh,
did mtvs half hour comedy hour and MTV.
Was that Mario Joiner or somebody else
saying yes and Mario would.
It was like,
I didn't even get to shake his hand,
like he introduces you and he goes to
the left and you go to the right.
And I was like,
damn,
I didn't get to shake my hand.
I felt like it wasn't even really on a
show,
you know?
It's like Mario joined her back then was
the shit.
That's a guy where I don't understand
what happened there.
I don't understand what he was.
The shit vanished.
Anthony Clark was the wholesale a
kamikaze or something like those guys.
But I know Anthony,
I know he's troubled,
so I know that's what.
What would lead him to this weird place
he is now,
but I never understood the Mario Joiner
thing.
Right.
Do you remember Reggie Mcfadden?
I do remember is another one,
right?
Adam was a monster.
Absolutely.
One of the few guys that I really would
would be afraid to go on.
Okay.
I used to see him in the early nineties
in New York and I would watch him do
stand up and I would go,
fuck,
this guy's going to be Eddie Murphy
who's going to be gigantic.
It's going to be the biggest comic ever,
and then nothing.
It was weird.
It's the weirdest thing ever as he stole
even.
Exactly.
Exactly that question right there.
That's hilarious.
And charismatic guy,
handsome and well spoken and a fucking
really nice guy,
like a real nice guy and whenever you're
around him,
he's always smiling,
having a good time.
It's like,
what the fuck happened?
How does this not work?
It's a very strange thing.
It's a very strange thing and it's a
very strange thing when guys get angry
that for some reason or another they
don't get the respect that they deserve.
That is one of my pet peeves.
That's a weird thing when people do
that.
Well it's because,
I mean,
I can't speak for Reggie,
but it's like,
you know,
you,
you go through this phase or period and
standup where you're like,
okay,
I've committed my life to this.
This is what I want to do.
I've,
you know,
I'm all in here at the table.
I'm in my,
for me,
my mid twenties,
there's no turning back now and there's
a bunch of those years where you're
watching people go on,
you know,
some people are getting stuff,
some people are falling off and it
freaks you the hell out.
Man.
It freaks you out hard.
But I don't think it's a very healthy
attitude at all to look at someone
else's success as if somehow or another
it's bad for you.
You know?
And I think if some,
if you're not,
if,
if someone's not paying attention to
you,
like there's a lot of dudes that like,
you know,
I don't feel like my,
my advocates or respect that it
deserves.
Like he gets the exact respect it
There's no other way around it.
It's the perfect connection between you
and an audience.
And if it's not getting a reaction,
it's because of one of two things.
Either you've been very shitty and
marketing yourself and,
or promoting yourself or your.
You're not seeing it the way other
people are seeing it.
You haven't found your audience and
there's some people that have weird acts
like,
you know,
Mitch Hedberg for the longest time had a
really hard time on the road because he
would go on and they would put on these
like super high energy middle acts that
would sing.
And like,
I remember there's this black dude in,
oh,
I believe it was in Ohio,
I think it was at the,
uh,
the funny bone and Columbus and Hedberg
was supposed to headline and this guy
was fucking crushing air every night in
the middle spot with singing and dancing
and getting those Columbus,
Ohio people into it.
And then Hedberg would just,
you know,
your folks who's from there,
it's what it is.
That's your peeps.
They're good people.
That's where I recorded my special
there.
But he would,
he would go out to them and they would
hate him.
He would hate him.
What was he in that face to remember?
You just grow up and kind of.
He would stand there for a while and his
hair were just completely be covering
his face,
like not even looking up the glasses,
nothing.
He was just like the top of his head and
how do you go up after somebody is
fucking juggling chainsaws,
which is hilarious by the way.
Yeah,
it is a weird thing,
right?
He had a fine his audience and he had a
real hard time with that a long time.
That's always a tricky thing,
man,
when you're coming up in the beginning,
like there's guys who will tailor their
material or tailor their act where they
don't want to do this,
but they do it just so that they can get
more people liking them and they can get
like on a better track.
You know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
There's that,
that's like,
that's like a real.
It's like,
it's so hard to fucking.
Especially when you don't have an
audience to really find your own voice.
You know,
it's so tricky because you know,
you'll work at a club and if you offend
someone,
I feel like,
you know,
my act was always kind of dirty and
offensive and like,
you know,
when I was nobody,
like they would get upset at me.
Like you just,
there's three people that want their
money back,
fucking asshole,
you know,
clean up your act for the next show and
you're like,
wow,
clean up.
My Act.
Like this is what I like to do,
this is the stuff that I always like to
see.
Like I can't talk about what I think is
actually funny.
So when you're doing your stand up and
you,
you did finally leave Boston and hit the
road where,
where did the news radio thing finally
mtv thing and I got a development deal
right out of it with Fox to do a show
called hardball.
This terrible shows really bad,
but you know,
a bunch of good guys on it and I had fun
but it was like I don't want to be run
actors and even when I'm like,
this is just to grow.
So I would go back to New York and go
back to comedy,
but I fucked up and already got an
apartment because I thought the show was
gonna.
Everybody thinks their show is going to
go though the ratings are good.
Were picked up for next year,
you know,
everybody thinks that show is so.
My stupid ass got this fucking cool ass
apartment.
And I was like,
all right,
now I'm stuck.
So then right after that I got a deal
with NBC and before I know when I was on
news radio,
it was just like stumbled into one
thing.
I mean audition for news radio.
But uh,
it was kind of funny because one of the
reasons why they liked me for the part
was that there was no jokes in the
script.
Right?
Like the first one that gave out there
was no,
it wasn't no comedy in it.
It was just like really straight and
flat.
And I was like,
wow,
I don't know how the fuck do I play
this?
I was like,
I'm just gonna play it as if I was
really saying it,
like,
let me just go and do it.
This is,
there's no jokes in here.
So I don't know what they're doing.
They were just trying to weed out the
hacks.
They were trying to read out the.
We were trying to weed out exploding
shoe guys.
I guess so.
It just got lucky.
It's total luck.
Total luck,
right person,
right place,
right time,
click,
click.
All of a sudden I'm on TV,
which was fun,
but in the beginning when I was on TV,
I I've very shitty with writing new
material and W I wasn't performing that
much.
I was just loving the fact that I was
making all this money and just having
fun and doing stupid shit and just no
discipline at all.
And saving up for your first incredible
car.
I bought the first car right away.
Soon as,
as soon as I had money,
I bought a 1994 Toyota super turbo.
Had One of those to do those with the
shits.
Used that fucking big crazy wing in the
bank.
Literally a spaceship.
I loved it.
Loved it.
Was my first really cool car.
I think I went a 85 Mustang gt with the
tee tops digit charcoal gray.
She was abused.
It's nice.
Yeah,
it's a.
there's something fucking cool about
buying your first cool shit.
I bought a pool cue for $7,000,
but this Ernie,
Ernie cutera's,
this guy in la,
it makes us Cuculla Gina Q,
Right.
Homemade,
like really like precise,
perfectly balanced pool cue.
It's like this thing's called
seven can collect anything.
Do you have anything that you'd like
spend money on?
You get the.
I know we both get Steve Martin junk.
We both collect Steve Martin.
Stuff like a bunch of members.
Yeah.
I went back and found a whole bunch of
old vinyls,
Lenny Bruce and cosby and new heart and
a Steve Martin and stuff.
So that was kind of my thing.
Like I like finding stuff that that's
off the beaten path as opposed to like,
all right,
anybody can go.
I think for me the craziest car I did an
Aston Martin.
Oh yeah.
And I thought okay,
I spent a quarter of a million dollars
on this car,
was going to be the fucking craziest.
Got the best car ever.
And it really ended up being the worst
thing that I ever bought with my money.
Dude,
I had the exact same story with Porsche
nine slash 11 turbo.
I bought a nine slash 11 turbo and it
broke down on me,
literally broke down where it needed a
tow truck five times in three years.
I think I drove you three times.
Did I dealer?
Just me.
I've spent A.
I was there like nine different that we
were complaining to the fucking crap.
The crap.
A Lexus
never fucks up.
Never.
Never fucked a bulletproof.
Yeah.
They make them so well.
There's never any problems,
but if you have a Mercedes or a porsche
or something like that,
you're going to have some weird light
goes off.
Like,
what the fuck is this?
This isn't working.
Why is my headlights not coming on?
Shit.
You got to bring it in.
Close the computer and I bought one in
windows 95 on those things.
The Aston Martin and then I bought the
Casino Royale Soundtrack.
Can I just fucking drove up and I
pretended I was a spy.
He was pointing at people on the side of
the road and pretending I was shooting
them and like too much time on your
hands is a problem with those cards is
when they work.
They're intoxicating.
You know,
when you hear the sound of the engine,
that fucking powerful,
like well engineered engine,
but it was such a poorly crafted car
inside that.
I was like,
why don't I just get a fucking ring tone
of that sound and be happy with the
fucking side of the engine and get rid
of this plastic piece of shit ass.
Everything inside was crap.
It's in an English car,
right?
Yeah.
They've never been known for really
making great cars mean Jaguar,
I guess.
Yeah,
but the engine,
you're right,
it was worth a fuck up to before Ford
bottom,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
English.
You don't want that.
You want Japanese.
They don't fuck a product.
Problem is.
It's like everything's made by robots
now for the most part,
so even American made by the same robot.
Not the same though.
It's the standards that you engineered.
That's what's important and they're,
they're.
They're using much higher standards than
American car companies are.
There's no doubt about it.
I have a Ford Mustang and I have a BMW m
three,
and the difference between them is so
different.
It's Ford as high level as far as
American cars go.
It's better than gm,
but it's still.
You're inside of it.
It just feels fucking Chincy and things
feel goofy and they don't.
The navigation system kind of sucks.
It was like is engineered by an American
guy and was just kind of.
Whereas the Lexis,
it's like everything,
right?
Yeah.
Let's fucking do this.
Modern complained about cars.
How sad also had the cast of all time
we've had.
We've had
nothing is.
Well that's the thing is you can
actually,
you can sit here and you can tell these
stories if you've been fortunate enough
to have some success because anybody who
knows who's done this for a living when
it's bad,
it's fucking bad.
When it's empty.
It is at its emptiness,
man.
So you know,
you get a little something or you have a
few years of fond that I think it's to
cool to be able to kill.
It doesn't seem real to me.
You know,
success and money.
None of it seems real to me.
You know,
when I can go to the store and just buy
things.
Yeah.
Oh look,
that TV looks like it would be perfect
right there.
Let's just get this thing and it can be
a piece of plastic and you give me
whatever you got.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
I've never real.
It is.
It's crazy fake,
doesn't it say I to walk around your
house?
I know you don't smoke pot,
but when I do I'll walk around my house
high and I'll just look at the house.
I'll just call.
What the fuck is this like,
um,
this is my house is where I live.
This is so strange.
Like why you think about what it was
like when you first started making money
and you didn't have to worry about bills
anymore.
You know,
that feeling.
That's the fucking most liberating
feeling ever.
That's the big feeling.
It's not being famous,
not being rich.
The liberating feeling is not have to
worry about paying your bills.
That's the most important one.
It was like,
wow.
It was like all of a sudden it just like
lifted.
Like I literally physically felt
lighter.
I'll never forget it because I was
always scratch and it was always like,
do this John Schuler Gig and maybe I'll
have enough money for rent and then you
know,
I can't eat tonight because I,
you know,
I literally don't have any money.
I have to wait until tomorrow.
And my check cleared.
Yeah.
Down still owes you a of chats.
Was the big one especially imagined.
Yeah.
He still owes me 300 bucks from one of
those.
Really those,
that was brutal for people that didn't,
don't know what we're talking about.
There was a time where there was another
entity that he had called New York
entertainment,
right.
And they were booking colleges and
apparently it was costing too much money
to rent the building where they were at
and they were spending more money than
they were making.
So they started spending the comedians
money and owing it to literally like you
would,
you would go to the Gig,
you would fly around the country.
You go to these colleges,
get your checks,
send them into Barre and then you know,
you would wait and then you build like a
month later.
But like,
what the fuck dude,
where's my money?
This is getting crazy.
And then it would be like another time
you would do it like three or four
times.
There was guys that had like,
they had a lot of money out.
I don't know how it all got settled,
but it was ugly.
It didn't
do it around that 300.
And I'm like,
no,
it's my good luck charm is not paying.
I have the,
I'll show him fucking theory going.
But I know for me man,
like seriously,
it's like what put things in perspective
and people,
some people know this or don't you know,
I,
I hired my step brother,
my half brother.
Yeah,
I know that story.
That's a crazy story.
And it was like,
all right,
so I thought I had this great nest egg.
I bought a house,
I did all that.
And then he
came in and you know,
I can't talk too much about.
It's ongoing,
but
we're gonna be talking about it since
you can't.
So the rumor is you don't have to say
anything that he stole like $11,000,000
from you.
That's fucking hard.
Five years you think that your fucking
brother,
your beloved,
like someone you grow up with is so
fucking jealous and so shifty and
plotting against you that they'll steal
your fucking money,
allegedly,
allegedly had been such a betrayal.
That's it,
man.
It really was.
First of all,
absolutely complete betrayal and the way
I deal with that with my family,
but the thing that really was jarring in
the best possible ways was talking
about,
okay,
I've been doing standup for.
I been doing standup for 20 years.
Um,
you know,
when,
when everything happened,
I started in 1990 and then I looked and
I was like,
alright,
this is gone.
I never had this either it was gone or
whatever.
I went back on tour.
I did probably the biggest tour that I,
I'll ever do last year I did 80 arenas.
I went out there and fucking just,
you know,
it was hammered.
Yeah,
the economy was Shitty,
but I kept going.
I was promoting my fans came out and it
was that I haven't had a moment in a lot
of years.
We're really struggling.
Really struggling again where you're
like,
I'm in trouble if I don't do something
and the ride is over,
what do I have left,
what's there for me years down the line,
and I was really thankful that the fans
came out and support it,
but it was that moment where I'm going,
okay,
you know,
yeah,
I bought some cool shit in my life and
I've collected some album Israel,
you know,
buy something crazy or tomorrow,
but you can't fucking take somebody's
creativity.
It,
it always comes back.
You'll have stuff you'll lose.
I've had things,
I've lost it many times in my life and
all you can do is keep getting back on
stage or fucking getting out there and
doing whatever you know,
connects you to something.
Yeah.
That's what it is really for comics to.
It's putting the new thing together,
right?
Yeah.
Sweating that new chunk and then the new
sat and you know,
preparing for the next special and
feeling these new bits come alive and
the tags and the new tags,
like what a burst you get every time you
come up with a new tag.
It's like this positive energy charged,
like Ah,
look at it,
and then sometimes on stage in the
moment you'll pause and say the perfect
shit out of nowhere and destroys and
that becomes the closer.
I mean,
that becomes the part of the bit that
ends the bit
best feeling on earth man.
Really,
when it all starts to come together,
you see that,
you know,
it's like you have a theme or through
line that starts to come through and
there nothing better in the world,
man
in,
right from the bat,
right from the get go.
When you have your first good set,
you become a junkie for that feeling.
You become someone who needs to kill.
You need to get up there and killed and
you don't want to do any new.
You don't want to fuck around and do any
new shit.
That's the problem in the beginning
because you're scared and you want to
make sure you get through the set good
and you just just do this stuff that you
know is going to work.
Don't fuck around,
don't fuck around.
Right?
And said hampers your growth because you
become this fucking junkie.
You just want that charge.
Just want to hear them scream.
You want to hear?
Oh Shit,
no.
But we,
we also,
you know,
we came out of Boston where,
I know the,
that I can.
I mean I loved,
I love Steve Martin and the guys that I
always loved just watching growing up
that I wanted to emulate.
And then when I started in Boston,
these guys were like,
killers,
man.
What people don't understand about
Boston is everybody knows all these
famous guys.
Everybody knows billy crystal.
Everybody knows,
you know,
I mean in the very good comics,
Robert Klein,
but I blah blah blah.
Name the guy.
Don Gavin was better than all of them.
Yeah.
He was better than all of them.
And this is,
this is not an exaggeration.
And he was fucking squeaky clean.
I mean,
every now and then he said,
fuck,
fuck.
A little less than that.
But that his bits,
we're not dirty.
It was.
Delivery was perfect.
It was perfect.
He would watch his economy of words,
the way he set a sentence up and you
would just feel humbled.
You would be like,
fuck,
he's a master.
He's a master,
but he got caught up in this Boston
thing where there's all these great guys
in this one area and they always drew a
crowd and they always got paid well,
and then they would go on the road and
they'd be nobody's.
They'd be like,
why would it be a fucking nobody?
We've got a about back in Boston.
Next thing you know,
they're back in Boston and they're just
doing the same gigs over and over again
when everybody else takes a shot and
branches off and disappears and becomes
famous
and it.
But you really would watch these guys
and part of you would feel bad that they
weren't getting over the hump,
but you felt like so fucking honored to
be opening up and standing,
watching going,
I'm learning from the best.
When you leave Boston,
it's like you had that.
These were guys like.
I always describe it like they had the
energy of showman,
but they were like men.
They were men.
Doing comedy?
Yes,
yes.
And I,
you know,
I always really wanted to be there.
They always stood right at the fucking
front of the stage or re Lenny Clarke is
the perfect example of that.
When Lenny's a fucking man,
he's a guy.
This is what Lindy Clark said was we
were at giggles and Sagas and there was
this fucking table full of chicks.
They wouldn't shut the fuck up.
They were screaming and yelling.
He goes,
listen,
if you don't shut the fuck up,
I'm going to hire a Nigga.
Fuck you in front of your mother.
What the fuck did he just say?
Me and it was me.
I think Chris Mcguire was there.
I think it was me and Chris.
I can't remember if we were like,
what the fuck did he just say?
He doesn't give a fuck.
Buddy Clark did not give a fuck.
He was just this big,
gigantic burly guy who would,
by the way,
he would beat your ass to who this is
like if you like talk shit to Lenny car,
he'll probably,
you know,
do a line and punch in the face.
These were real like real hardcore blue
collar guys,
but layering area.
It made us.
It made us sharper because you were held
up to a much higher standard.
You had to go on after guys who were way
better than average and you had a.
You had to be sharp all the time.
You had a.
You had to constantly reassess your
material.
You did it.
I learned a lot watching joe before us
because the thing that happened with you
though was you were the first guy that I
saw from the next young generation that
when you started headlining,
you were getting the respect for,
for killing,
but you were the first guy that I saw
that had real backlash ever in my life
that people were like,
they didn't know how to,
where to put them and people that he'd
passed.
Nope.
Not going to mention names,
but like they were just so fucking
frustrated and they didn't know how to
deal with like,
okay,
wait a minute.
This is an,
this is the next guy coming up.
There's that.
You know,
people are always going to resent and
you're young.
Good looking in every fucking chicken.
The crowd after the show is just like,
you know,
there's that,
there's the fighting thing too,
which doesn't make any sense at all.
It's not supposed to.
They're not supposed to coincide
together.
The martial arts thing,
it just seems like I'm,
I'm not the,
I'm not,
I'm not in the club.
You know,
and I mean that's what it felt like to
me.
People are always going to be backlash
when whenever anyone successful,
I don't have to tell you that.
Oh yeah.
And I didn't fight,
which makes it even tougher.
You know,
people are always looking for some
reason why you're fucked up when you are
more successful than them.
They're always looking for some reason
why it's them,
you know,
to you and not them.
You know,
people get upset or other people's
success,
you know,
and you could feel it,
I mean,
I got hate mail when I was on fear
factor every day.
There's no getting around it.
You're always going to get someone who's
fucking mad at you about this,
that or you don't deserve this,
or you're short or you're bald,
or it's just constant.
People you don't even know just wanna
before the Internet with that.
That even exists though.
The Internet's just hate it.
Well,
it's not that the Internet is,
hey dude,
the internet is an outward expression of
how people feel.
People are frustrated and angry and you
know,
look,
we've been shown that we live in a place
where we have a fake economy that is
recognized as fake by everybody,
but we're still pretending that it's
real.
We print up money.
Nobody understands where it all goes.
Everybody's fuck.
The banks are making billions.
We don't know how,
you know,
there's a lot of frustration and anger
in this world and if you're anonymous,
you fucking mcfuck stick on the Rogan
board and it was decided to be a cunt.
You know,
it's just so easy to lash out.
Dane Cook and suck my Dick.
You know,
I,
I asked for questions and of course most
people like on my message board,
most people real cool shit.
There are some interesting questions for
you,
but there was a few,
there were just so fucking douchey.
No,
you're never going to get away from
that.
Those are people too that they really
want so badly to perpetuate a moment or
something because they want to see the
fucking battle.
They want to see the battle and there's
also this thing where they don't want to
see anybody ever forgiven for anything
and they might have done in the past,
right.
Because they can't.
Yeah,
they can't.
Yeah.
And that makes it okay that they can't
if you can't or we can.
Yeah.
I out last year on a couple of cans
back,
but yeah,
no,
totally.
It's,
you know,
there's,
there's just a lot of people in this
world that not just,
they don't just feel shitty,
but they're lashing out.
They lash out at other people.
They do it for no reason.
Like I can imagine like see,
like if you don't like a movie,
like I saw a serious man last night.
It was fucking terrible.
Why would you watch that?
Like all these stars on it.
Five stars.
I.
Dude,
I didn't.
I didn't go to rotten tomatoes.
I should've.
It was a Coen brothers movie too and I
love the Coen brothers and there's some
really interesting parts in it,
but there was a part of the and where I
was like,
oh my God,
it ended.
It just ended it just like,
okay,
now the movie's over out of nowhere were
way worse than this.
I was accepted the soprano's I was
figuring like,
this is a long story.
It's over.
That makes sense.
I was just like,
I don't even know these characters.
All of a sudden,
boom,
it's over.
So I wrote on twitter.
I was like,
a serious man.
Seriously fucking sucked.
You know?
I was like,
well,
am I hate or am I doing that ticket?
I'm like,
no,
but I'm a this.
I'm a fucking reviewer here now.
More viewer now you fucked me out of two
hours of my time.
I feel like I deserve something back.
Yeah.
Plus you said it as Joe Rogan,
not fucking mcfuck steak or whatever.
Yeah,
I think the message boards would be,
I tried it on my board for awhile,
tried to make everybody put a picture of
themselves and I said maybe we be nice
to each other if we used our actual
photos of Atar,
but it only lasted for like a little
bit.
Everybody wanted to be fucking darth
vader or something.
Chicks dig somebody.
All the avatars on by border.
I'll check suck a dick.
Somebody likes it or somebody just
recently tried to do that.
Whether you had to have your real name
on their message board,
but then all these pirate privacy things
going on.
Right?
Yeah.
Blizzard.
The uh,
those games.
That's right.
Yeah.
Do you do gay?
You're a Gamer,
right?
You do like online gaming a lot or not
like I used to.
I mean I used to have pc stuff and then
you,
I did console for a little bit but takes
up too much time.
Not like a once in a while I'll still do
like call of duty or something,
but you want to play for 11 hours in a
row when you do that.
I get so addicted to it
online video games,
it's,
they're so addictive.
When like quake,
like first person shooters,
I've talked about this many times.
I used to play 10 hours a day.
No bullshit.
Yeah,
that's how we actually kind of really
first met.
That's how we met and bonded before the
big,
uh,
the big breakup.
But it was like a.
I remember you were telling me about
alienware computers and all that shit.
So I went out and got one.
I basically got the computer,
he told me he had,
which I didn't have the money for at the
time,
but joe's like,
I got this,
it's a rig and area 51 fucking.
I went and got it.
I was living in this shitty little
studio on Hacienda and all I had was a
Fuckin futon and my alienware computer.
I don't really know anybody out here
anyway when I first came out,
but I jumped on with Joe once while I'm
think like,
all right,
quick three or whatever playing he would
like just Roy,
right?
He just not even destroyed.
It was not even fun.
Not even like,
it was just bad.
It was like beyond rape.
Yeah.
He,
he'll do like kill me like 99 times in a
row.
I don't even think I killed you once
maybe like three hour period.
And I'm like,
dude,
not only would joe be plasma rifling me
up my ass like every other hit,
but then I'd hear through his whatever
the headset,
like he'd be doing something else which
made it even fucking worse.
Like he,
I could tell he was not even completely
focused and sweating and doing that
thing where I'm like trying to sound
like I'm not fucking raging on a good
shot.
Joe.
Turn off the Mike.
I'm like,
fuck,
come on.
Quake is one of those,
those
games,
for those who don't know it,
it's a first person shooter where you
running down these three deed mazes and
you have all these different gun options
and it's one of those games that relies
very heavily on playing it all the time.
So the mouse and the keyboard literally
become like an extension of your mind
and you can get it to do what you want
it to do because you're so comfortable
with the movements you don't think
about,
you know,
it's w a s,
d use the keys to move backward and
straight side to side.
But you don't think about it,
just do it.
It's just like I'm going to the right
when I go to the right,
I'm thinking to the right now as I'm
thinking my fingers and moving and you
get totally sinked up with it.
You have to do it like eight,
10 hours a day to day.
So I was obsessed.
I go online,
that's what I would do it.
And I'd be like having conversations
with my check and I'd be thinking I
could be playing quake right now
completely.
So I would have to pretend that I wanted
to see a movie with her.
I was a complete junkie.
What was weird is that you are really
competitive with the game where like I
would just hide in the toilet paper roll
of the unreal bathroom map and just sit
there and snipe people where you're more
like kill every number.
Second.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
my leftover martial arts days,
there's still some work to be done in
the back of my head,
so just fucking just running down
hallways,
shooting people.
This thing is so satisfying.
It's so fun.
I remember it was over when I was at
fry's electronics try to buy like shit
that I've been thinking.
I'm like,
is there a mouse that has every button
already on?
Like what can I do to fucking guys never
beat me.
By the way,
God's would do the same thing that I did
to you.
To me it wasn't.
It wasn't that many guys,
but every now and then you run into like
a Chinese virgin,
some 13 year old kid who doesn't give a
fuck and he just every day,
15 hours a day just staring through his
bifocals at that fucking screen blast
and do deserve rape me.
It would happen all the time and I'd be
like,
Oh fuck.
I thought it was good.
Guys would go down and interview with
rail guns.
Impossible shots.
You just,
you showed up for a second.
Your Dad,
you're like,
motherfucker,
some guys are just just on another level
and now kids have all the modded
controllers and I'm just using a regular
controller.
So I'm like,
I'm never going to have the advantage
anymore.
They've got like these,
uh,
you know,
whatever wolf pack fucking sticks and
it's like nine
deal with the console,
you know,
the console is just not as precise.
And they did a thing with a Microsoft
started.
They did a competition between console
guys against a
keyboard,
bass guys yet.
But you would never play that.
You get used to the point.
If everyone's doing the same controller,
then everyone's on the same page,
do you know?
But the same controller isn't as
precise.
Why would you use that controller?
Yeah.
When you got another,
you can get really good at it.
I mean,
you can't get as good,
right?
For what you like to play your kind of
first instruction side.
You want to have the most connection
between you and what you know,
how fun it is to get on your ex boss.
Go,
Oh,
Carla Smith.
See is playing call of duty.
Let's kill him a little bit.
Yeah,
it's so fun.
Do you ever kill him?
I played him once.
Really?
Yeah.
Is he any good?
No.
Really kick his ass.
I don't think.
I think I was more just like watching
him.
Like I said,
I hang out in the toilet paper because
I'm a video game foyer.
I went to his website the other day for
something because I.
every now and then I'd like to read his
twitter and go,
what the fuck?
Just so strange.
So I went to his website and it said one
of the most feared in the country.
That's like on his bio,
on the front of his book.
He's the punisher.
One of the most feared.
Like what?
A crazy thought.
You talk about the wrong psychology for
comedy,
one of the most feared you want to be a
feared comedian.
What is that?
What does that even really mean?
That's so strange.
Do you collect comics?
What the fuck are you talking about?
We're talking about Carlton will be
changing gears like that.
That's ridiculous.
We're talking about someone completely
crazy.
Yeah.
I don't really know what that means.
Who wants to be a feared comic?
It's horrible.
It's a horrible way of thinking.
You want people to fear you.
Who's going to fear you?
The audience.
Comedians.
Well,
what he likes to do,
and you know,
he talked about it on the mark baron
podcast.
I thought it was really fascinating that
he used to it,
but when he called back,
what's that?
Because he went,
he went in.
It was kind of,
you know,
what's weird?
Marin was like,
it was very strange.
It's very strange conversation,
but I don't,
I didn't understand why Marin didn't
understand that he's completely insane.
Causes like gone.
He's like bipolar or something,
like there's something wrong.
But when,
when,
when you started talking about,
um,
about uh,
the,
um,
uh,
during the podcast,
what was it exactly?
Oh Shit,
now I'm trying to remember.
Fuck God dammit.
I can't remember what the crazy part
was.
Oh,
one of the crazy ones was did you tell
me this one that he was saying that
some,
some troops that someone was thinking
about killing themselves,
but they read his shit and are they saw
him perform and they didn't kill
themselves.
Then,
you know,
it wasn't me.
Well,
I'm making shit up now and I'm just
giving them room and he was talking
about how he would go onstage in front
of guys on purpose to make them feel bad
that he would.
Yeah,
he was.
And he talked about how he did it to
mark Marin.
He talked about how he did it to a.
what's that dude's name?
I'm Steve Trevino.
First Time Steve Trevino ever got the
headline,
Carlos went on right before them and did
like an hour,
an hour,
45 minutes or something crazy.
But when he was talking about he,
he comes like he's paint that.
He did it.
That's the thing that's associated with
this fake.
I had to manage what I had to do.
It's like why?
I think he's like,
he's like,
he's broken legit,
sociopath.
Where it doesn't.
He doesn't feel emotions way everybody
else does and I don't think he feels
when he's hurt either.
He's got like this weird block going on.
It's.
I think you're talking about my brother
and I think we're talking about a lot of
people.
There was a book written recently called
the enemy amongst us or something like
that.
Something along those lines and it was
all about sociopath's,
about how many people amongst us really
don't feel emotions.
They just pretend they do to fit in,
but they don't fear the consequences of
their actions.
They don't worry about hurting other
people's feelings.
You know?
That's a.
that's a fucking real problem.
There's a lot of people like that.
Yeah.
I think I'm on the fucking complete
other side of that,
man.
I.
I'm one of those people.
I feel like I feel everything want to be
a comic.
You have to be fucked up,
right?
I mean,
you will.
We would all admit to that.
You have to be sensitive.
You have to be.
You have to be insecure.
There's got to be something inside of
you that wants attention so badly that
it's willing to go through those early
days because you know,
if you're not fucked up,
you're going to find something better.
You got to find something that doesn't
hurt so much,
you know,
but that need to be special.
It's got to be so strong that you're
willing to get through the bombing.
Right,
right.
I just remember being so afraid in
because I was like the complete,
not only introverted,
but I always like,
I had like anxiety and social anxiety.
I still really do.
Actually.
It's funny because I can do huge fucking
arenas if the meet and greets 10 people.
I'm like,
alright,
what are we doing?
But in high school was really bad and I
remember feeling like that,
uh,
that first time I got a laugh that light
broke up a moment and it was like,
oh,
that's the fucking weapon right there.
I want people to fear my comedy wants.
What is that?
My first one I did out of anger,
I had this really shitty math teacher
who was always mean and she would just,
you know,
just treat you like you're really dumb
if he didn't understand things and she
was a black lady and she was uh,
doing this thing on stage or on the,
uh,
on stage she was doing this thing in
front of a chalkboard,
but she was writing something down.
I wasn't paying attention and she goes,
Mr Rogan,
would you like to come up here and do
both of these questions for the class?
And I said,
would you like me to do both of those
questions?
And everybody went fucking crazy.
Like tubes could not help,
but they just don't laugh in.
And people slamming books down and then
she kicked me out.
I got sent home for the day.
But I remember thinking at that moment
like,
damn,
I just got that bit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's when the soundtrack starts,
man.
No,
I know.
After that it was like,
she's being mean to me,
you know,
it was like an,
I shut her down in front of everybody
else.
Like Dan,
that was my first heckle,
I just remember skipping school one day
and I was at Brigham's Brigham's sure.
And I was just sitting there in my,
uh,
Mr Hall,
the guy who was like,
the house dean came up,
but I'll say,
just sat in front of me like I was
busted and he goes,
um,
and I was starting to do like plays or
like write stuff.
And he goes,
he goes,
listen man.
He goes,
I know school's not for you.
He was the first person to like,
he goes,
I know school's not for you.
I know that theater and you know,
making people laugh.
You're kind of caught up now.
He goes,
that's really what you should do.
I know you wanted to be a comedian.
That's what you should do first person
to ever tell me you should do that.
So nice to have someone there to say
something like that.
Yeah.
I never had anybody telling me that.
Everybody told me I sucked my,
my own mom told me she didn't think I
should go into comedy because I wasn't
very funny.
I think that's more of a mom protecting
herself.
Sure.
But for sure.
But God damn lady,
my girlfriend,
my girlfriend does comedy because she,
she watches her friend do and it's like
embarrassing.
She feels bad and she's like,
Oh,
you don't want it.
She just doesn't want you to eat it and
watching somebody eat is hard.
My friend Eddie,
you know we've talked about that.
I've got Eddie to do stand up nine
times.
He's a funny guy.
He says like really funny shit,
like always.
And I'm like,
dude,
you could totally be a comic.
I'm like,
within two years of fucking around and
practice and you'll be opening up for me
on the road.
I'll help you.
I'll cut out a lot of the time,
the development time,
like,
dude,
you could be a comment.
Just listen to me.
I can help you said,
fuck yeah,
I'm going to do this.
So I is.
And he just fuck it.
Over and over.
The bombings were so disastrous.
It was so hard to watch.
It's funny how like people that we know
that are funny and when they tried the,
it's almost like they land on stage,
the furthest place from what really
actually makes them funny.
You're fucking interesting.
Yeah.
Well they just don't know how to be
perceived.
They just get confused as to how they
should be perceived.
It's just they want,
they want to like,
they want to like somehow knew that like
fit this mold of what they think is
going to be funny.
It's like the connection between them
and the audience is so distant and
fucked up and Jag in there's barbed wire
in the way.
Just it's for most people,
they don't understand that in order to
be able to be yourself and get onstage
and talk in front of somebody,
you have to like really know what the
fuck you,
how you're coming off.
You have to really know yourself in a
way that a lot of people aren't covered.
I'm looking at themselves,
yeah,
you have to you after.
It's.
It's about being revealing and then
finally not giving a fuck anymore that
people don't like what they see and then
you can slowly find the people that like
what they see and build the last from
there,
man,
and it's got to be a real,
not give a fuck.
You can't be on pretending to not give a
fuck like you have to have mastered it
to enough where you've understood the
situation and you've assessed it and
you'd been objective about the whole
relationship between the EU and the
audience over and over again.
So many times that you will completely
mastered it and then you're comfortable
with the experience and then only then
can you go up there and just be yourself
and fuck around and be funny.
Right?
But until you hit that vibe,
that one groove,
you know,
you,
you're just go out there going,
clunk,
please love me.
Please.
What can I do to make a connection with
you?
And you get it like little bits or touch
you at all,
but it doesn't grab you and hug you.
You know,
in the beginning days like every now and
then you'll,
you your crack like one bit.
That was like,
oh,
it has a something there and people
would laugh.
Ha Ha.
Like I think there's something there.
I think I,
I'm touching.
There's gold under here and we'd keep
digging.
Fuck,
it's hard.
Listen to yourself a lot like you record
your sets and I really,
I never used to until I,
you know,
you make cds and then you have to,
which is brutal.
And also,
I mean I remember listening to the first
cd and I went,
okay,
at that point in my life there was no
real drama in my life.
There was nothing,
nothing dramatic about my life.
It was pretty easy going.
A lot of my first stuff was very
nostalgic and very kind of like,
this is the stuff I grew up with.
We,
it's fun.
That's what I knew and as I listened to
that I was like,
all right,
two things.
First of all,
when I listened to myself,
like I would say 40 percent of it,
there's no words.
It was just physicality and that was
what I started really getting passionate
about vernacular and wanting to build up
a,
you know,
language and paint better stories with,
with words,
and not only that,
but I,
I started having things happened in my
life and my personal life with,
especially with my folks that really
were
like,
alright,
you know what?
I'm not a kid anymore who just goes up
and talks about fucking or,
or you know,
Frat,
you know,
kind of humor,
drinking.
It was like,
I have real issues,
real problems,
but now how do I turn a corner and how
can I,
you know,
it,
it takes a while to be able to not
reinvent but like how to have a
metamorphosis onstage with truth and
light where you're at in your life.
I feel that all the criticism that
you've gotten,
and I can see this for myself,
all the criticism that I've gotten,
even the stuff that hurts and even the
stuff that was wrong and just hurtful,
it helps me absolutely improved me.
Even the Douche bags of improved me
because it's made me look at myself
through their eyes and go,
okay,
do they have a point?
Like what?
What is it about me that's offensive to
them?
What is it about me that they don't
like,
you know,
and,
and then you see it and you go,
oh,
okay,
I can see how maybe I'm being kind of
Douchey or like I've had bits from my
old CD's,
I w I would like to go back and change
it.
I was like,
I don't even want that being represented
of a representative of my thinking.
I like that.
Any specials that air and people just
discover you and they're like,
oh,
is that what you do?
I go to England a lot and I love it over
there,
but I had an old bit about just shitting
on England of fucking stupid.
It was like other women are disgusting
and it was just a mean bit for no
reason.
I just met a couple of English people.
I didn't like his this crazy bit,
but now it's like I want to say like,
I don't really think that way anymore.
This is just douchey shit.
Yeah.
I definitely looked back.
No regrets because everything builds you
up to where you're at,
but for me when it was like,
okay,
I finally hit a crossed over and I.
I remember I knew I had a moment where I
was like,
okay,
what all the Djs in the country,
we're really talking about me.
That's what I knew.
I was in trouble.
That's what I really battened down the
hatches and I was like,
all right,
I know what two years from now I know
the way this is going to go and I know
the way it's gonna come back and you
know what?
I just took it.
I took it on the chin.
I pretty much fucking just kept showing
up doing my thing because when,
when the pendulum swings into the good
area,
it's going the same fucking direction
and the other area,
man,
it's really,
there's a real backlash for somebody who
works hard to get attention.
That's a weird thing about people when
you work hard to get attention,
if you get attention and people like
people love Dave Chappelle and one of
the things I love about Dave Chappelle,
he's,
he's very reclusive.
He,
he goes onstage like weird.
It'll show up in a park with a fucking
PA system and do a show.
It's weird,
but when people promote a lot and
people,
uh,
you know,
get their name out there a lot,
there's a backlash for that always.
Why is that?
I don't know,
man.
What the fuck is that?
I got that.
Well,
I mean I did that because in 1998 I was
sitting around doing nothing for most of
the day except waiting for sets.
I just come out here and I was watching
a documentary on fucking punk bands and
they were showing them put up like,
Hey,
we're dragon face.
And like literally,
you know,
nailing their flyers to telephone poles.
And I remember sitting there going like,
this is what I need to do.
Whatever the modern version of that is.
I need to fucking build a fan base.
I need to like some kind of grassroots
thing because I'm going,
I don't want this to pass me by and,
and then what do I have?
Nothing.
I'm at nothing
else.
I'm really shitty at a lot of things in
this world.
Really bad.
I think that's the only way you ever
make it as a comic.
If I had other career paths,
my other career path was brain damage.
My other career path was kickboxing.
I'm like,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to get brain damage for no
money or I'm going to become a comic.
Well,
I don't have any other skills.
I don't have a college degree.
What the fuck am I going to do?
I can't work.
I'm a shitty worker.
I would show up at construction
gateshead last two weeks,
pocket the money and then quit and like,
fuck this tar roofs and it was like half
a day and I'm out.
Yeah.
Boston man.
Those people fucking work hard and you,
you know that there's an east coast
coast work ethic because of the fact
that it snows there and it gets deathly
cold in the winter.
People are hard,
right?
They fucking work,
man.
They get up at seven in the morning and
they're at work by eight and they
fucking work all day in the snow and the
Sun Ninety fucking degrees out,
hammering nails that.
That's a hard gig bro.
You construction in Boston and it's
like,
you know,
you're doing that,
but when you know those people were
cutting into your shows,
probably why the guys before it's,
it's like you better give them a fucking
show.
Fuck yeah,
you better work really hard job when you
come home tired and you just been a guy
who kind of went from college to comedy
and kind of drifted through.
You don't appreciate people's attention
spans people,
especially on Friday night,
10:00,
shout there fucking tired.
They are tired,
you know,
those people worked all day and they'd
been drinking.
Yeah.
Comedy is such a fucking strange thing,
man.
It's so strange.
It's like it is our connection with
something.
That's what it is.
It's like everybody's got their own
connection to it and you know,
and everybody's trying to figure out how
this guy connected and how is he
connected.
Yeah.
But you're the best guy at connecting
with the Internet.
You,
you are the very reason why I started
myspace page.
I read an article about you in people
magazine.
I was at my dermatologist checking to
see if I had a fucking staph infection
because I do Jujitsu.
You get Zits,
you gotta get them checked out because
it might be staff.
So I'm sitting there and I'm reading
this article in people magazine and it
said you had $300,000
space fans.
And I was like,
you fucking imagine I go 300,000
people.
You could just send out an email with
300,000
people.
My,
that's incredible.
I'm like,
that's fucking brilliant.
So I started myspace page that day and I
hired my friend Duncan to take care of
it.
My friend Duncan got a job and my friend
Dunkin's jobs just add friends to my
space age and you know,
and uh,
I'd send them blogs and he put up my
blogs and shit.
Like
I love it.
How attached do you seem like you always
are?
It seems like you answer every.
Almost everyone's like,
I've talked to so many people that
you've answered like twits or my spaces
or facebook.
Are you really on the Internet that much
or you that or do you have like a staff?
Oh Man,
I never had anybody else logged into my
stuff ever.
It was always,
always may.
Still,
always.
How much time a day do you spend
responding to emails?
Do you still use my space?
I know cook gave up on you,
bitch.
When Dane Cook gives up on my space,
that's like Tila Tequila.
That is still on.
She's still swinging a fucked.
They
don't take care of their home.
They don't.
They don't and they haven't touched it
since and it's.
There's so many stupid things like
adding friend request.
You know that hard.
There's two.
They're not sexy anymore.
You know something.
Something else sexier came along that
got it right.
By simplicity,
not letting you put fucking glitter tags
and every time I go to your page,
music starts playing and yeah,
weird hearts fall,
but you always had the best pages man.
Like on my space.
And just personally do you do at your
design yourself?
I learned html code,
I about like html for dummies because I
literally had nothing to do all day and
if I wasn't playing video games right,
I was fucking bored man.
I was bored and I wanted to.
I treat honestly.
It was like,
alright,
this is politics.
I need to shake hands.
I need a kiss fucking babies because I
want,
I want money and I don't want to live in
this fucking shitty apartment with A.
I think like Don Harris lived downstairs
would just be fucking screaming at
people don't know.
He hosts a thing called the Ding Dong
show at the comedy store and it's all
the most psychotic open milkers.
There's,
there's certain open microbes that are
like completely delusional and
absolutely insane and their acts are
just so bizarre that you can't believe
that real well.
Don Baer is puts on a show specifically
with those people.
It's fucking genius,
but he's always surrounded by nothing.
And you were Polanski and windy city
heat.
That was one of my favorite movie,
favorite things I've done.
I just rewatched.
It was like,
holy shit,
that's Dane Cook like the first time.
Never realized it was us,
still have not seen that.
I still have not seen it.
It's great for people who don't know
that they.
They punked this guy for a whole movie.
Right.
And Kim oil pretty much swept in,
made a whole movie,
pretended this guy was famous and they
had.
The guy's crazy.
I mean,
they're basically taking advantage of
Harrison.
He was always at the comedy store.
The guy who was always there and they
had this guy convinced that he was
famous and it worked.
But basically it's kind of sad.
I mean they're picking on him.
It is sad until you finally hear the
stuff that wasn't in the movie and just
how fucking evil he is.
Oh,
he's crazy.
He's crazy.
You know,
I,
I feel like he's just a broken person.
Yeah,
he's.
Well,
he's weird.
He's a Weirdo
that's broken.
It's weird that like being a facebook
friend with him too,
because he is still talking about that
movie today.
I want to leave his car.
Read is crazy shit.
Oh yeah.
I fucked up.
Read a fucked up and Ted Haggard banned
me.
I was loving reading his crazy shit.
Yeah.
Who's your favorite twitters and people
to follow on twitter and do you have any
like guilty,
like Ted nugent's or anything like that
or wish Ted nugent was on twitter.
I tried to find him.
He wasn't in there.
Dammit.
Fuck.
I've got all kinds of crazy dudes
online.
I love it.
It's like a party that I put together
with all these nutty people that never
be together.
There's a thing called flip book now
too.
You've got to get this app bad on your
ipad.
What is it?
It's.
It's a fucking APP that makes you plug
into your facebook or twitter and it
turns whatever your feet is into a
magazine.
Yeah.
You with the pictures in the magazine,
so whatever the links are,
it makes it like an article like
Hollywood reporter or People magazine
and you flip through and then it's just
like it'll be your fucking face with one
of your quotes.
You've got to see this med school and
already report type.
It's cool dude.
So good as policy.
I got Paul's.
Yeah,
that's good.
Yeah.
If you want it basic.
I love the IPAD,
I've got stuff.
I've been working on an app too because
now that's the new thing,
man.
It's like,
you know now everybody wants.
You got to be in somebody's pocket.
People don't want to fucking log into a
site anymore.
It's like,
dude,
I don't wanna.
I don't want to mess with all that.
Be In my fucking pocket.
An APP
working on right now for this podcast,
for a Libsyn,
Libsyn,
the company that's hosting us,
they make apps for you,
so it's really cool.
When they host your podcast.
I'll make you an iphone APP.
Yeah,
you have a couple iphone apps are used
to have.
I took them all off.
I did have one with this animal and
those guys,
which is great.
They did an amazing job,
but I got a company working on a new app
now with just the whole push
notification thing because I mean I
think one of the best companies out
there for like when people are talking
about promoting,
how can I promote?
I'm a musician,
I'm a comedian,
whatever.
It's like these things like say now St.
that's a little you call up and leave a
little voice message,
but it hits everybody.
Everybody who joins your say now if you
send a text,
it's 100 percent fucking guarantee.
Everybody's going to get it and you can
go regional.
If you're going into New York,
do shows you can hit New York with the
St [inaudible] voice message.
Hey,
tickets today if you guys want to come
see me,
it's last minute as opposed to my space
or whatever.
You're hitting like point.
Oh,
four percent of people who twitter like
if they don't see that stream,
right?
Twenty minutes later,
if you repeat it like an enterprise,
like you're spamming promotionally when
we want to get the word out.
So it's like mailing say now
people that I actually go to their
twitter page and like read their
personal tweets just to see.
But you have to do that.
You have to go back and like,
oh,
this is funny or this is a cool link.
Like you have to go.
There's no way you're gonna catch it and
if you have like tweet deck or something
like that and there's no way you're
gonna catch it.
Just so you've got to.
How many people do you follow?
You follow?
A lot of people are like 70.
That's it.
Damn my fault.
Hundreds.
I think I fall like 500.
Yeah.
And I was missing so much that like,
but now you can do lists.
I have was
on there either.
So many cool people to follow.
Right?
I love like seeing like religious people
right next to porn stars.
It's all right.
There you go.
Like this.
Like you're doing something to them by
forcing them to cooperate together.
If this is a party,
this would never fucking work.
Bring politicians and porn stars and you
know,
I,
I try to just make it as weird as
possible.
Any fucked up person.
Haters are fun.
A lot of haters and I add them to all
kinds of weird fucking people.
Man.
I will say this.
I have every email that everybody's ever
written.
Me a serious.
Yeah.
I figured out like this method with Mac
mail years ago of like,
and I have everything in folders,
man.
It's Kinda crazy,
but I've every military email I have
every fucking like I have one called
Weirdos and it's just bad shit.
Crazy.
They publish
a book on that.
I should man,
because I've had a couple of interesting
stockers.
Dude.
I've had a couple of fucking really?
Really?
Yeah.
You want me to throw them out for a
little shout out?
Like a story that we were talking about
before the started doing this.
That's one of the reasons why I won't
talk about it on the air.
Them to know that.
Interesting though I,
I'm sitting there right now going into
me.
He sent me my,
my favorite was the wireless ceo mail
that we got after that video.
How much?
Like crazy.
Oh,
angry,
angry Mexicans.
Terrible writing.
I mean I saved a bunch of them.
I had a whole folder called Carlos fans.
It was just the most ridiculous messages
that I got.
It was shocking.
Just shocking how dumb some people are
out there.
What's weird about the whole text
messaging and everything?
Like somebody I know,
I'm not to say it is calls me all the
time,
never texted me and I won't even answer
the phone anymore because it's just like
stupid questions.
I think the phone calls to dying,
I think to the point where I do too.
You know,
I,
I'd rather be making calls in my car.
Yeah.
When I'm hooking up to the Bluetooth,
I can have cool conversations.
You know,
when I'm driving for an hour or so
later.
You can text though,
like,
no.
Why would I want to do that when I can
have a conversation in the car?
That's silly.
You,
you would rather text and have a
conversation,
Huh?
Yes.
Really?
My problem is I have like a really weird
creative head where I thought I start
thinking about something and somebody
calls me during that I,
I lose it.
So like I'm just connecting my phone
man.
Yeah,
I know.
But then I don't know.
I'd rather be in this motor.
Go,
y'all do it.
Then you're not committed.
I told you that right room.
That program that I use,
this is what I do.
I disconnect the phone,
I shut off my cell phone,
I tell everybody,
leave me the fuck alone.
I'm going to write and then that's it.
I go back there and write with right
room.
All you see.
Have you ever used that for writing
shit?
Check this up.
And like my mom says,
listen,
your mom talked to my mom for 15
minutes.
I want to shoot myself.
Check this up.
When you use it,
it um,
it makes it turned into the whole.
This is all you see on your desk,
you see is green tax and black screen.
You can't,
you can't access your task bar,
but smart you can do anything.
The only thing you can do is you could
quit and you know,
that's hard man.
And that keeps you focused.
Totally focused.
And I shut my phone off,
I write and I ended up seeing shit pop
up.
Yeah.
Or you know,
you just think maybe I should just beat
off.
And then you just go start checking out
porn sites and spanking went off.
Yeah,
I hear you're writing a book right now.
I'm trying.
That shit's hard,
man.
That's probably the hardest things I've
ever fucking taken on.
I'm writing one right now and I won't
let anybody help me.
People came were like,
you're going to hire this guy and no one
will ever know and Zach and so and so
used to them and I'm like,
first of all,
that's pathetic.
And secondly,
fuck this.
I want this to be the hardest thing that
I ever accomplished.
Yeah.
I want to make sure that everyone knows
that every word is in a certain order
because I wrote it.
That's what it is.
It's all of it,
right?
It's the best representation that I can
come up with my thoughts.
But you're a great writer.
I mean I've read some of your stuff.
It's like you don't need any help in
that department.
Well thank you.
But I think everybody does.
You know,
I think you use a,
in the beginning especially,
you could use someone else's.
I,
you know,
someone else who sees what you're doing
and has a different opinion on things.
I think that's very beneficial.
I've given my stuff,
you know,
to friends or people that I trust to
read it after the fact,
but so in that sense they help.
I mean,
you get feedback.
I think I'm definitely a better writer
now because of all the feedback that
I've gotten from people through the
years,
you know,
it's like the same.
It's like comedy in a way.
But the thing is,
you know,
it's like your connection with the
writing.
Sometimes it's um,
it's such a hard thing to describe,
but sometimes the words come to you when
you're writing,
you know,
when you're onstage,
you're performing and you know,
you know,
you'll,
you'll get in the groove and you'll bits
will come to you at a,
out of thin air.
But there's something even crazier about
it when you're writing because when
you're writing,
sometimes I'll get through a whole
paragraph and then I'll go back and read
that.
I go,
God damn,
where the fuck did that even come to?
Yeah.
It's like it just came out of space.
It's like I'm in this weird
semi-conscious state when I'm running
where you're just like,
so zoned into what you're doing.
And as you're zoned in,
the sentence is just sort of form
themselves in your head and then they
changed their position and no,
this isn't in the beginning.
And then you read it again and it offers
you another perspective.
Yeah,
it just all starts.
It's like literally like you're tuning
into something that comes out of,
it's in the air somewhere.
It truly is like the most incredible
form of therapy that I could.
I mean,
after my,
uh,
my folks passed away,
people were like,
you should go talk to somebody.
And like I was bringing her onstage but
I wasn't.
And then I started writing and then
reading some of the shit that I was
writing and realizing I didn't even know
I felt that because you just get in that
fucking zen place where you're like,
I'm not even looking at the keyboard,
I'm just putting it out there.
And then you read back and you're like,
Oh man,
I didn't even realize that's how I
connected those two things together or
so.
I mean,
I love writing.
It's just writing a book is tough man.
It's very important for comics too.
There's a lot of guys who don't like to
write,
they just liked to perform onstage,
come up with funny ideas,
which is a great way to do it that way
does it,
but you're not going to get the best
shit.
Sometimes you're going to get ideas that
come to you when you sit down and just
write and then you could take those
ideas of stage and fuck around with them
and tweak them.
But if you just try to go onstage,
just come up with stuff onstage.
It's not the same.
Right?
Yeah.
You have to have like a little kernel of
something.
I mean I can,
I can improv if I know what I want to go
up there with,
but I hate getting caught.
Just leaning.
You know when you're leaning up there
going like what else?
You find it really hard when once you
do.
I find it very hard once I do a special
and then I know I have to do new shit
and then I'm really like piecing it
together and I'm always doing a million
different things.
Is once as as you are too.
I'm always doing a million different
things so it's hard to fucking pci those
new shit and then you got to do a new
show and you're like,
fuck these people probably already see
my special,
you know,
just aired fucking shit new shit that I
got.
I got like 40 minutes new shit.
Bring that back.
It's 45,
but I don't even like that.
But you know,
ticket things that I hate bringing stuff
back that I've done before just feels
Rodan and feels like you're a shithead.
You're cheating,
you're,
you're robbing them or something like
that.
Unless they ask for it,
if people scream for it and if I can
remember it,
that's a problem.
Like some of the yellow,
like Anna Nicole Smith,
like I can't do it.
It's like seven minutes long and I don't
even know.
I know,
I know some of the punchlines.
This may sound super fucking cheesy or
something like Bon Jovi would do,
but during my last tour I would bring
somebody up out of the crowd and I'd be
like,
you know,
the fucking Koolaid bit because I
haven't done it and I'm watching them
act out and they know the kick that I
would do or the whatever,
physical brick and I'm just like,
this is crazy.
That's actually pretty fucking cool.
You know,
I started out doing comedy.
One of the reasons why I did come in the
first place was reenacting qbd and spits
that I saw on TV to my friends.
I was like 18,
19.
Like I remember there was a girl that I
was working with.
I was working at the Boston Athletic
Club in South Boston and I was a fitness
trainer.
And um,
this girl that was working there had
seen Sam kinison on Hbo.
And so she comes up to me and she goes,
do you gotta see this comedian?
He's so fucking funny.
He does this bit about.
It's the craziest thing I've ever seen.
She gets down on her stomach in the
parking lot,
doing Sam kinisons bad,
about a bit about the people having sex
with the gay guys having sex with a
corpse and he's.
She's lying down in the parking lot at
the athletic club and she's like,
so here these guys are.
This is how he does it.
He,
these guys are the line of slabs.
Like,
Oh my God,
I'm going to go to habitat,
be with Jesus.
Said,
Oh,
what is this?
I kept taking my life keeps fucking in
the ass.
Even after your dad.
She did that bit for me in the parking
lot and I was howling laughing and I
instantly became obsessed with standup
comedy and with Sam Kennison.
I was like,
go,
I have to go watch this.
This is the craziest thing I've ever
seen.
It took a long time to fuck.
I gotta get a vhs copy of it.
Right?
And I finally got to see it.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
So that would you say would that.
That was obviously one of the moments
that like diff or defined your formative
years in standup comedy?
Yeah,
there was that and there was a,
when I was a little kid,
I was about 13.
My parents took me to see live on the
sunset strip and uh,
Richard Pryor.
Yeah,
my parents were hippies and uh,
my sister was like 12.
She went to Shit.
And so we're in this theater and I
remember laughing so fucking hard.
I couldn't believe in it.
It's kind of funny about standup comedy
man,
because Richard Pryor was one of the
most brilliant ever for sure,
but honestly,
when you watch it today,
some of it is very dated,
you know,
it doesn't hit me the way it hit me back
then.
And that's the case with music.
That's the case with a lot of things.
Lenny Bruce was one of the greatest I've
ever one of the most important pioneers
of comedy ever.
It's very hard to laugh at this stuff
now because the culture changes,
people's perceptions change and comedy
changes and there's.
The comedy that you do today would
probably be too shocking for people who
lived in.
It's like comedy is defined by its
certain era,
so if you go back and live in the sunset
strip today,
it's not going to hit me like it hit me
when I was 13,
when I was 13.
I didn't know anything about comedy.
I couldn't believe there was someone
that actually saying these there and he
was saying it's so perfectly.
I was crying,
laughing and I remember looking around
at this theater,
I'll never forget this.
We're moving forward and the chairs and
rocking back and forth,
and I was thinking,
I've never seen anyone laugh like this
in a movie and this guy's just talking.
I'm like,
I was thinking about stripes.
[inaudible] stripes had been out at
least one of the greatest comedy movies
ever.
I might get stopped this funny.
Nothing is funny.
This is crazy.
This guy's just talking and that.
That was the first big seed.
That was huge.
That was just the seat of my fascination
with standup,
but until I got people that told me that
I could do it,
I did not think I could do it.
I was doing.
I was teaching taekwondo and finding a
tournament's and these guys that I train
with,
I would make them laugh in the locker
room and on the way the tournament's
because everybody was scared on the way
to tournaments.
We were all good.
We're going to get kicked and punched
and shit.
It's fucking terrifying and a lot of
guys got knocked out and you get to see
your friends get knocked unconscious by
getting kicked in the head.
So there was a lot of like gallows humor
on these trips,
you know,
we were just trying,
so I would always be the guy that would
like do impressions of all the different
teammates having sex and all that stupid
shit and that's how I got to talk to,
to doing standup comedy,
man.
But fuck it.
Some stand up comedy.
It's got to be one of the fucking
weirdest jobs to ever enter in every
because no one could tell you how to do
it.
Yeah.
I'm trying to tell other people what it
really is.
We could talk all day.
You know when you're,
when you're at your best,
when you're locked on onstage and
crushing,
don't you feel?
Or do you feel,
because this is how I feel,
I feel like I'm just writing it.
I feel like I'm a passenger,
you know,
I feel like I'm tuned into this whole
thing,
but I feel like as everything's coming
out and I'm hitting all the things,
it's almost like I'm just,
I'm just,
I'm on autopilot.
I'm in,
I'm in some crazy groove where I'm
getting to watch this and I'm getting to
experience the words coming out of my
mouth as they happen.
I have no idea how the fuck it's all
working so smoothly.
I really can't even take credit for it.
That's interesting because I like,
I can't speak anywhere nears flawlessly
is when I'm on stage.
If I tried to tell you a bit,
I will stammer.
I will fucking not remember and I can
groove on stage sometimes like surfing
where you're like,
I don't know how I'm staying up.
Wave for an hour.
Just like
just that intensity that there's,
there's an intensity of communicating
with people,
you know,
just like every cylinder,
everything in your brain fires up and it
cranked.
There's that Steve Martin Accordion born
standing up where he goes,
I can feel it in my fingernails.
I point out I can feel it in my foot the
way it just moves and plants.
I can see every part of my body.
It feels like it's emitting fucking
standup.
Yeah.
He hated being a standard.
Oh my God.
He hated his.
The adulation that came when it became
immediately gigantically successful and
he couldn't get an honest response from
people anymore.
They would start screaming and cheering
as soon as they saw him and he would do
these gigantic arenas that he couldn't
control and they were just totally out
of control.
Right.
Which happens to a lot of guys when they
get big.
Like,
you know,
Chappelle when he was touring,
he would be really frustrated when he
went after the Rick James Sketch sketch
came out because people will be yelling
out everywhere.
I'm Rick James Bitch.
He'd be in the middle of setups on like
James Bitch and they couldn't kick out
enough people.
It was just,
it was too nutty.
That's the,
that to me honestly,
when dice was at his peak when I first
was watching the HBO specials,
you know,
I was young comedian specials and then
he had that.
I remember feeling like,
how the fuck can I do this but not be a
character?
How can I do this and be as real still
be an entertainer,
still be on but be as much me.
So there's none of that fucking
catchphrase.
Got to see people,
you know,
everybody wants to be a little Mark
Twain.
You want your Shit quoted?
Yes.
But not like that.
Not like that.
Not a t shirt.
Do you keep that weird feeling?
Huh?
You know,
it's also like when you are first
starting out to accommodate,
how old were you when you first got
onto?
Nineteen?
Was 18,
18 and 19.
I was,
um,
I was 21 and I was not a fully formed
person yet,
you know.
So it's like,
you know,
when you're on stage yet either.
I'm sure when I'm 60 I'll look back at
myself now and go with the fucking shit.
Were you talking stupid?
You know,
you know that feeling,
but I,
I know that,
you know,
I did not have anything to say.
There was no reason for me to be there
talking.
There's,
I really didn't know who the fuck I was.
I didn't know what I was saying.
I could show you how to kick somebody in
the face.
I really didn't have any opinions that
were valid on anything else.
I mean,
what the fuck?
What's my opinion on anything?
I could tell you something silly.
My girlfriend did want,
she was blown may or something.
I could,
you know,
that's it.
But other than that we'll fuck.
How are you?
And I threw it off a little bit because
you were saying like,
so then when chappelle started doing the
bigger shows because yeah.
Even Steve Martin,
he lost control of the fucking.
Did you what?
How quick was the jump between you doing
clubs and you're doing these giant
places?
Giant arenas.
It was actually a slow but steady
trajectory where when that web stuff,
what happened was this in 2001,
my first real website that I put up in
combination of napster starting to get
hot and me uploading all my shit too
that with the link I literally uploaded
clips with me at the end going visit
[inaudible] dot com at the end of every
22nd clip.
Then comedy central,
I did a half hour presents that I
thought,
what are fucking taught?
I'm like,
okay,
there's the one with you and the tank
top tank top dude.
I thought,
all right,
you don't want this whole air.
A couple of times maybe I got to light a
fire.
Were to bowling fucking shirt with the
car.
I don't want to look like what anybody
else did.
I just want to do some crazy shit.
Maybe people fucking pay attention.
Never realized that they were going to
air it five times a week for like two
years.
It built my whole fan base in almost
immediately went from a few hundred
seaters to,
you know,
a couple thousand and that I'm doing all
the college stuff and over three,
four,
five years.
The,
the
instant messages during those schools
renting out the arenas at the schools
and it just built.
How much time do you spend everyday
talking to fans,
emailing,
you know,
facebook and twitter and all that shit.
I'll tell you man,
I don't.
I used to talk to everybody.
I used to reply to everybody.
If that was at the beginning,
that was from 2000 2005.
That's really what I did most of my day.
And then it got to a point where you
don't need to read all the fucking crazy
shit that comes back and you know,
there's just too,
too many opinions and too much
negativity.
So it came down to I'm replying to
troops.
If I get letters for like and I can
check check by the email somebody,
you know,
one of our troops rights or if it's like
a kid I write back.
I've been trawling as a kid for years.
So don't assume I agree with that.
Twelve year old gets advice from him.
No,
but it took a while,
man.
It was not like everybody.
There's that old expression or took 20
years to be an overnight sensation.
It was a long time man.
It was not.
It was not as instant.
Maybe as some people thought it's got to
be satisfying
though to know that you know,
you went out here and you did some
movies and shit and some things didn't
connect and didn't happen well for you,
but you did it all on your own.
Like everything was done through your,
your own.
Figuring out how to self help,
self promote and you changed everybody's
attitude about it.
No,
comics are good promoters except I mean
there's a few.
It's very rare.
But until you came along,
no.
Comics were really good at self
promotion.
Totally changed my attitude towards
you learn that from your father.
Right?
I did,
man.
A couple of things that I want to give
credit to joe too,
and I told you this a long time ago,
like you were the first person to have a
website,
not only your website but you had cool
shit on your website,
man.
You got fucking cool designs and fucking
that as a director,
result of my obsession with quake
because I was obsessed with quake and I
ran into this Guy Andrew,
who is this guy that I met online.
Wait clan.
Just how fucked up I was.
I'd have all these dudes online from
like Kentucky in Oklahoma.
They would come a fly to California and
stay at my house.
This is when I was on news radio.
It was on TV and dudes would come over
my house that I didn't know from were
just my quick buddies and they would
come over and stay at the house and I'm
not bullshitting.
I had like five dudes come over my house
and we had a land party.
I was so obsessed with this that I.
I put a t one line in my house because
back then you couldn't get any fast
internet.
You get ISD,
which is not quick enough,
so I said,
okay,
how much is the t one line?
It was a thousand dollars a month.
I'm like,
let's do this.
Okay,
so they fucking have to install this
business grade internet lines.
That's why you.
I was completely bought into the 33 six,
but what is,
it's Your Ping,
your pink time was you could be on 56 K,
but if you're really close to the server
you're paying.
It's all in how fast.
It's all really just how much you do it,
you know,
just become obsessed with sure.
You start to know your frame rates and
where you're going to fucking click and
bounce them.
So dangerous.
Getting really addicted to things like
that.
You lose your life.
Yeah,
right.
Do you worry about doing shit like that?
Like things that are,
that eat away your time,
relationships,
marijuana,
dare you.
No.
I mean,
listen for me,
all I ever ate,
all I ever wanted to do is create.
That's it.
I,
I'm not,
I don't have any other fucking
abilities.
Uh,
you know,
I really just,
when I was a kid I had that epiphany
moment where I was like,
all I really care about is being around
performers,
talking about performing,
talking about,
you know,
making something from nothing.
And you brought up my dad was like,
that's my favorite conversations in life
were with him because he was the kind of
guy who go,
yeah,
I don't,
you know,
you're a lot of talk,
Dane,
uh,
I want to see shit.
And it was like he was just motivating
men.
That's important,
man.
That's important.
Having people that don't totally
completely believe in you,
you know,
it is absolutely important.
The mom was like,
oh,
I think you're the greatest.
You're the best you shoes.
So fucking Uber supportive.
But my dad was like,
yeah,
you're not a,
you're not really doing anything
in order for you to develop the kind of
fortitude that you're gonna need to get
through the hard times.
You have to have something to prove.
That's what I think.
I think it's too hard.
If you don't,
it's too hard to really push yourself.
Right.
You know,
if you don't have a chip on your
shoulder or something to prove or some
gap to fill,
you're not gonna you're not gonna do it.
Can I get through that?
Think about all the guys that we started
out with that we're just as good as us.
There was a lot of guys that were very
commensurate.
There were all really.
Think of them happened to that guy.
Fuck man.
Like I used to kill.
He used to have this one bit and used to
destroy and they just could see that guy
on evening at the Improv.
I could see that guy,
you know,
Ryan headlining and he just stopped,
stopped down at girls too.
There was this chick,
Leon Lewis.
Um,
I,
I was an open mic or with her.
Do you remember her?
She had some fucking good bits,
man.
She was still trying to figure out how
to go on stage and had developed.
But as a comic,
like,
as a,
as a chick to especially,
it was very like honest and out of
nowhere and like,
well written shit.
I was like,
wow,
this chick's got huge someday.
I'm like,
she's going to be like,
eleanor just disappeared.
Just fell off.
Just where'd you go?
It's weird.
There's so many fucking so many slots.
So many people going towards these slots
and some of them just,
it's just too far up though the salmon
ladder that just fuck this.
Just can't do it.
Dan,
you should use your Hollywood
connections to get a.
John Hughes was just about to release
the extra hour of planes,
trains and automobiles that they filmed
right before he died.
That what happened to that?
Now it's done.
It's probably all in the family.
The family probably owns it and they
have to figure out the rights if that's
what he wanted.
I'm sure they'll probably release it
still.
Why would they want to keep it?
Well,
they've kept it for what,
20 years,
you know,
he,
he wasn't going to release it ever,
but then just recently he was thinking
about it.
Oh,
well I don't know that unless it was in
as well.
Who knows what the fuck's going to
happen?
I was telling you before that,
um,
you know,
one Steve Martin moment.
That was really because I,
I had dinner with them like a few months
ago.
He sent me a copy of his book.
I was completely blown away,
but I'd never him.
I heard all this stuff about him that
he's Kinda like,
you know,
maybe not,
he's a little socially awkward,
all this shit and what a trip.
But as being someone that famous right
meeting really your hero to which you
don't want to do by the way,
you usually meet your heroes and you're
like,
oh,
that was sucked.
But with him I was like,
all right,
you sent me a copy of his book and I,
I wrote back just to be like,
can I,
could I take you out to lunch?
And he agreed and so I sat down with
them for a little bit and he's really
real.
Like I'm,
I can be shy,
I can,
I don't know about shy,
but I can still be like a little bit
quiet.
But he's very much like,
he won't say a word,
I don't think if you don't,
if you don't start the conversation with
him.
Wow.
But he did say to me at one point,
he goes,
uh,
he looked at me Kinda like perplexing is
like,
you look like you really love it up
there.
And I was like,
yeah,
no,
I really,
I really do.
You know,
when you're in the middle of it.
And I started kind of.
And he goes,
yeah,
I never had that.
Never.
I go,
not even at the end.
He goes,
I never had that.
I never felt connected when I found out.
I thought that,
yeah,
after that so strange what I have least
in common with Steve Martin's comedy.
What?
I wonder if his phrasing.
I wonder if it's just got some weird
connect in his mind.
Maybe he's depressed.
Maybe a naturally depressed person.
Well,
if you read a lot,
I read a lot of this stuff in the New
Yorker when he would write.
Oh yeah.
It's depressing shit.
Yeah,
man.
That letter to my father that says all
men.
And
I was telling Brian this,
I was going to bring this up,
but fuck it.
When,
when Phil Hartman was alive,
Phil Hartman was really good friends
with Steve Martin.
And Phil Hartman was going to a set,
Steve Martin up with a,
what I call it,
coyote when coyote is,
is these really kind of crafty
professional chicks that will fuck
celebrity guys in order to try to get
famous,
try to figure out some way.
And this is pre TMZ,
you know now and now it's like,
you know,
you really can fuck someone and all of a
sudden become hugely famous.
That girl,
that Jesse James Girl,
what's her name?
Bombshell.
I'm the Mel Gibson girl.
Yeah,
that girl.
Exactly,
exactly.
And then all of a sudden that,
that actually can parlay into some sort
of something.
I mean,
who knows the fuck you can do,
but you people have your name.
They know who the fuck right now.
And she was one of those.
She was just kind of creepy.
It's just like very insincere but really
hot and just really beautiful.
But you know,
just something vacuous there.
And uh,
Phil was going to set Steve Martin up
with her and uh,
I forget who it was.
One of the cast members was like,
that is the creepiest thing ever.
He's like setting her up with a
murderer.
He's like,
and this is before obviously Phil's wife
killed him.
He's like,
this,
this woman does not.
She's not into him like,
she's like looking at it as an
opportunity.
She's like a little assassin.
She's gonna move in.
I was like,
Whoa,
that is creepy.
And then I started thinking of Ms Dot
coyotes from then on,
like because that's how coyote is like,
look at your cat.
They accounting like we got here,
bitch.
I just gotta figure out a way to get,
you know those skybar chicks.
Will you ever go to the Sky Bar?
And once in a while cross street from
the comedy store.
We would always go there because it'd be
really easy.
You just walk across the street and grab
a drink and there was always like this
conversation.
Do you do coke?
Sometimes,
like always.
That's the whole,
the whole conversation.
He was like producers trying to talk
starlets into bed and coyotes preying on
like balding Jewish man with money.
I always hear her right for her.
How much of a mind fuck is it
when you actually met Steve Martin?
What is it when you're sitting there
talking to them like,
isn't it like,
Holy Shit,
how does this happen?
How can this be real?
Am I really.
I met Gene Simmons.
He came to my new year's show and I was
like,
Gene Simmons is at my show.
Like this is insane.
Like I saw kiss a bunch of times as a
kid.
I saw them in the seventies.
My uncle used to work for Howard marks
advertising,
which was a company that did their album
covers,
so I got to meet ace freely when I was
eight years old,
so I got to see them when I was really
young.
I got to see him live in concert.
Then I got to see him,
Kevin Jameson.
I went twice in the nineties.
We were like,
Holy Shit.
Two nights in a row we're seeing a kiss.
I mean fucking huge fan.
So all of a sudden gene semis is at my
show and I'm shitting my pants.
I was like really nervous for the first
time in front of one of my crowds.
I mean,
everyone's there specifically to see me,
but
fucking gene simmons is one of them.
I'm like,
hold on.
ICON is going to be entertained by you
about it.
I had to talk about it right away.
I'm like,
if I don't get this out right away,
that's going to be fucking with my head
the entire time.
I'm on stage.
Junior highschool,
motley crue.
I was listening to,
you know,
shout at the devil,
and it was like,
that was my anthem and I fucking went
crew and two years ago I'm at the laugh
factory and all of a sudden a madman
starts fucking running around the crowd.
It's Tommy Lee and I found out he's my
biggest fan ever.
Wow.
And here's the fucked up thing.
I will go to Motley crue and do devil
science and I had the [inaudible] thing.
He's fucking doing what I was doing at
his fucking show to me in front of the
fucking life.
Adrian,
I'm doing the same thing.
I'm going,
this is fucking wrong.
This is too fucking is the matrix man.
I met Tommy Lee and I was so shocked
that he even knew who the fuck I was.
I was like,
this is the weirdest.
He loves comedy man.
He's like,
he's into it.
He's fucking.
He loves comics.
He wants to or he wanted to at the time
fight kid rock and he wanted me to get
him a trainer.
He decided he needed to fight kid rock.
Forget Pamela Anderson's honor.
So he was talking to me about like,
who's a good trainer?
I'm like,
we can get you a trainer.
Like what you want to do Jujitsu,
you want to kick box?
We don't need to tell standing.
I,
Tommy,
Tommy Lee and kid rock.
That would have been one of the
satisfying of all times though.
Like at a musical,
I,
somebody punched somebody.
I think kid rock probably punched him,
I think.
I don't know who would win that fight,
but kid rock,
he's got that crazy white trash thing
going on.
You have to kill them,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
Like you,
you know,
you think,
you think he's down.
You're like,
we're done.
We're fucking done here,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
We're done.
We're done in the head with a bottle or
something.
You know,
he's out of his mind.
I would.
I would probably have to bank on kid
rock there.
Yeah,
I'd go.
I'd go kid rock.
But you know what?
Scrap Tommy's a long,
tall guy.
He's got a good straight right.
If somebody teaches them how to throw
it,
he's a drummer,
drummer,
parents,
man.
All that shit.
That's the difference.
It's like a speed bag all day.
Tommy might fucking boxes.
Eyes off.
Paint.
Paint,
paint for a drummer too.
People forget that.
Oh,
is a real drummer.
Yeah.
But how much does he drop?
He's a drummer,
like,
you know,
not consistently pool,
right?
Know he's not a God damn professional
out there beating it for Motley crue.
Right?
It takes a lot of God damn endurance the
drum.
You know,
you ever tried drumming?
What are you doing?
It's fake sleep.
Such a silly fuck for the folks on
Itunes,
facebook,
or a fake a.
That was a stoner purchase.
It was $7 for four different sleeves.
I've got ahold shirt.
Lauren,
you got a whole shirt,
like somebody sent it to me.
He's like,
man,
isn't this the fucking coolest?
Like I would wear it and I was like,
what are you talking about?
It's tight.
It's flashy designer tights.
That's all it is.
It's like you're wearing a rash guard
house,
but it brought out my falcon cuff,
you know like the Eddie wearable falcon
cuff.
Joe.
Did you ever get to as far as just
comics that you fucking dog coming up?
Did you ever get to do shows with like
know,
I don't know who you're.
Steve Martin was where like a Kennedy
Center.
One of those guys like Tom,
I rare is the closest I got to do shows
with dom at the comedy store.
That was big to me because I paid to see
don before ever did comedy and for
people who don't know dot Merera fuck in
the late eighties and the early
nineties,
he was a monster.
He still very funny guy,
but for whatever reason he doesn't get
as much attention as you know.
I think his act deserves went back then
he was,
you know,
really,
really popular and I paid to see him.
I was living in Boston.
I took my girlfriend to see him at
Nick's comedy stop and I had never gone
on stage yet and all of a sudden,
you know,
in Montreal at the comedy festival,
it's like I'm working with them.
Holy Shit.
And there's only like six years later,
seven years later,
whatever.
It was really fresh in my mind.
I was like,
holy fuck,
like I paid to see this guy and now I'm
working with them like we're doing a
show together,
you know,
or were pulled on the bill.
It's like people are coming to see him
and they come see me.
Like,
what?
That's crazy,
but you know,
that's not like,
you know,
he became a friend and it became normal
after a while,
but I never got to see like my,
I got to see a few of my real influences
live.
I saw Hicks live.
I saw him live like four or five times.
How was that?
It was pretty wild.
I saw him live and no one knew who he
was and here's an interesting thing for
comedy historians.
When Hicks,
when I first saw him,
he was very similar to Sam Kennison to
the point where it was like he was
stealing his essence.
I would say right now,
like,
you know the thing,
but it's a good.
That's a good way of describing it.
Right.
When I first saw him,
he was making kinison like noises and
doing like sounds like in between bits,
like the bit didn't go so well and you
do those,
this Kennison like thing.
I was like,
wow,
this guy was like connected to kinisons
like thing and it makes sense because he
was like one of the guys that opened
with kinison and followed them around on
the road,
but he got out of that quickly.
We all are influenced by other guys.
I know you had an Anthony Clark period.
I had a Richard Jeni period where I
stopped myself on stage and I realized I
sounded like my cadence and everything
was Richard Jennings who was a big
Richard Jeni fan,
but I was like,
I gotta stop my salary,
but I did a lot of people don't know
that hix had that with Kennison,
no evergreen,
but he thinks it's Hicks especially
because his dad have this,
you know,
this God who is an amazing comedian and
very influential,
very unique and,
but all of us have this weird thing
where we want to be like someone we
admire and sometimes it sounds like it
onstage,
but he stopped that after awhile.
I saw him once and he had it like that
and then I saw him again,
you know,
just like six months later.
And he didn't do any of that.
In the end,
he had a bunch of new shit.
I saw him do it headliners set at the
comedy connection and then a headliner
set literally like six months later and
there's a totally new hour and almost
like
he just,
he figured it out.
Right?
There's that moment we all have where
it's like you just something clicks and
you finally realize,
all right,
this is what I need to do,
or this is my voice or my truth,
or whatever the fuck.
When you think about it,
for a guy who's only human,
I believe when he died he was only 32
years old.
His ideas and philosophies and the
validity of his opinions were so
advanced,
you know,
for,
for a person of that age because really
like most 25 year old guys,
he was 25 when he's doing a lot of his
act,
right?
Most 25 year old guys.
You better shut the fuck up if you want
to tell me how the world's running to
stop just you don't know and don't.
Don't give me any nobody fucking nine
slash 11 conspiracy website bullshit and
you're fucking.
What are you?
Twenty four dude?
Really just don't,
don't,
don't tell me how to run the world.
Let's grow a little.
Let's get some life experience.
Then give,
give it to me from the perspective of
someone who's actually seen something,
but he was advanced to like 25,
26,
27 really relevant points and really
good material there.
No bad period.
And if you look at as material,
you know,
like there was no period where it was
bad.
It got better and better and better.
I think one thing that he,
he really latched onto and maybe it was
after going through the,
the chemists and influence was like,
and I appreciate it was like this
release of whatever emotion it seemed
was going through him.
He just allowed it to come out even if
it was mid other story or idea and I
would just watch that.
And I,
I remember thinking that was empowering.
I was like,
wow,
this is a place where you can go up and
you can fucking ring shit out.
And people,
you know,
with a joke,
I think it's like a good song.
Sometimes you don't know the lyrics to a
song,
you just love the fucking song.
You realize years later,
like,
I don't even know what they're saying
here,
but it doesn't matter and I think with
some comedians it's like it's not even
so much about what they're saying is how
they're expressing something emotionally
behind that.
Those are the guys that I always
watched.
I mean,
Carlin,
of course prior it was like,
there was truth mixed with just humor,
just random ideas.
No.
When I got to see two,
I got to see kinison become not so good.
Anything kinison who was my.
The guy.
Remember I told you that chick,
you know,
doing that thing in the parking lot.
That's what got me into comedy.
I mean literally that's.
That was the bug.
Planted it.
I got to see him perform live after he
had gotten really famous and really
successful and he would come on stage
with the two girls and the whole thing
and it was like I didn't laugh.
Yeah.
He stopped being funny.
He became like,
this caricature of this guy you listen
to louder than hell.
His first CD or whatever it was who
listened to that still today and it's
brilliant.
It's really good.
But if you go and,
you know,
you look at the stuff that he did like
right before he died,
it's not good at all.
Yeah.
Well he got caught up in that MTV wild
then.
Yeah,
you're right.
It was like the trench coat became an
out,
like almost like a costume.
Yeah.
Well dice for awhile kind of had the
same thing going on too where he became
the dice man.
You know,
the dice man was a character that he
used to do on stage.
Right.
And you should do these John Travolta
impression.
Yes.
I'm young comedians.
That's what I really liked him.
Thought he was really strong.
It was fucking brilliant and likable.
Charismatic.
Yeah.
I mean when dice burst onto the scene,
I mean I think I was right out of high
school and I remember thinking that was
the funniest shit I've ever heard in my
life,
you know?
And then hanging out with that guy at
the comedy store years and years later
and just like,
he's like a normal guy,
you know,
but now he is the iceman full time.
It was a character and now he's got this
leather jacket on and the gloves on full
time.
Now
I have a theory that it's like when
you're,
when you're a character,
not just a character,
but like look at any sitcoms or any
fucking throat history.
If you play a character,
especially with a weird name,
like if you're looking to poughkeepsie
or lundy,
right?
You like you,
but then you become,
okay,
I need to keep that hairdo.
I need to be recognized that era and you
play into it and I.
that's,
that's frustrating when you see that,
but it's why I never wanted to be a
character man.
I was like,
I'd rather change and not be as funny,
but still have certain fans and I've had
this happen.
I've had fans go through to like your
stuff back when I first I know,
but I was a kid.
I was talking about kids.
Shit I didn't.
I was still new.
It's like if I didn't change,
you would not fucking hang out and care
at all.
What I was doing.
Well,
there's people that are going to like
you at one stage.
You career not in another and that's
okay because that's where they are.
They are where you were at that stage of
your career.
Exactly.
You know,
whatever.
Sorry,
I love that.
I lost Ya.
I got some new people on the way.
I lost a few.
I got a few stragglers that that becomes
what you crave.
I really believe because at first you
just want to get to keep my fans.
I gotta I gotTa hold order.
I'm going to make them happy and when
you let go of that and you realize
somebody's going to check out for awhile
and then I had a guy write me an email
and he goes,
dude,
listen,
I,
I jumped on the hate train or whatever.
I didn't like you.
I listened.
Isolated,
incident,
hurt.
You're talking about your folks talking
about shit that I've experienced.
I'm back in Madame,
hanging out.
I've been trained,
but that's cool man.
That's like people that can check in and
out.
Like I respect that.
You know,
I do the same thing with music.
I don't always like what somebody
putting out,
but of course like perfect example that
exactly.
Doing sound garden
and then he was doing dog shit and now
he's doing soundgarden.
Right.
It's all right.
Awesome.
I'm still here.
All right.
I just,
I bought that other stuff.
I just wasn't into it.
Yeah.
But you know,
go ahead and take your chances.
Who the fuck knows what makes the
connection?
You know,
if you don't take that chance of you.
As soon as you start about like,
wow,
I have to do what they want,
then you're fucked because then you
don't even know what you're doing.
It has to be what you,
what's inside of you.
But that's how many guys do
you guys see this?
It's like,
that's why when people,
new comics come to you out here and
they're like,
what do I need to do?
I'm like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Who didn't come up here?
Because you're going to be like packaged
in immediately.
Like there's a stigma on you leave.
Well there were so many guys at the
laugh factory that became you,
um,
when you became famous.
But when it was starting to happen,
even when you were like packing Dublin's
all the time,
there was,
I noticed so many guys that were doing
you onstage.
I was like,
wow,
this is fucking crazy.
It's like,
here's these guys that have noticed
something that's working and they're
just jumping on it.
That's a fascinating thing to see.
You know,
like a whole new wave.
that there's a wave of guys that came
out of the laugh factory.
Jo Koy that sounds just like you and
Mitch Hedberg stand hopes there's all
these sorts of clothes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well a lot of Mitch Hedberg guys,
right?
There's a lot of guys that all bad guys
that were like pretty good,
good comments.
But they were like,
dude,
you got to stop doing that.
Yeah,
I know you're good.
You have some good jokes,
but stop.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
It's like doing Mitch Hedberg.
I'll tell you man.
It was good.
It was fascinating to.
Okay,
what had happened.
And it was like,
fuck,
I'm,
I'm famous.
I'm known.
People are talking about me when I'm not
trying to fucking get something going.
And the is like,
that was really,
they were setting this tempo and then
there were guys that you see come out.
It's a little flattering and weird when
you're like,
oh,
this guy is kind of like me,
and it makes you not want to watch
comedy because you're,
you're a little freaked out by it.
But then you know that over a couple of
years down the line as guys start
getting frustrated,
those same guys were the ones who would
come out of the woodwork and say,
oh no Dane fucking took from me.
I was doing that shit.
That is true.
That will happen.
And guys will forget that they stole it
from you.
That does happen.
They'll forget that they got the idea to
behave that way from you.
And they'll decide in their head somehow
that they were doing at first.
But you guys would do that.
But you know,
it's like,
like you just nailed it.
It's like you,
you,
you take that,
you have a voice,
you have certain people that you want to
emulate and then you figure out your
shit and you grow out of it.
And I'm as kind of understanding and
cool about that because I've been up,
down,
up,
and it's like,
but in the beginning though,
you don't feel that way in the
beginning.
You feel like someone's stealing from
you and put a stop to it because when
you're not famous and you're,
you're struggling and you're coming up
and you know,
and you just starting to do well and
then you see somebody start ganking off
you and you're like,
hey,
I created all this excess of the at a
hard work and you're just kind of like
emulating it.
Stopped doing that.
Like you're,
you're doing what you saw,
be successful.
You're doing a version of me.
Right.
That's tricky,
man.
That's a tricky thing.
It's a tricky thing because it just
feels like someone.
I mean it really.
You got to let them do it.
You know what I mean?
Look,
if you become successful just through
the merit of your own work,
it's going to be really clear who's
copying and who's,
you know,
who's imitating who,
but it just doesn't feel like that in
the beginning,
in the beginning when you don't have
money and you're not like,
if someone's doing me now,
I'm like,
you have this guy,
why are you doing that?
Like,
wow,
I guess that's what happens,
you know,
and flatter even though it's still,
but you figured they would be done with
it.
I mean,
I was doing it when I was an open Miker,
you know,
I was doing it like it was a year in or
two years in,
you know,
I would hear myself sound like somebody
else,
but when someone's doing it and that's
their act on comedy central,
you're like,
okay man,
you took this too far.
You have to do your own thing.
You have to have your own delivery.
Yes.
And you know what,
it's funny because the first time in my
life I ever ran into was with you when
we had,
you know,
it was like 1998 and Joe called me up.
I remember I was still living in that
shitty apartment and you're like,
dude,
there's a fucking bit that you're doing.
And it's,
it's like my closing bit.
I remember I was so fucked up by that.
Not only because it was like,
you know,
I had a lot of respect for Joe,
but it was like,
I don't ever want to be one of those
guys that gets,
you know,
put in that position.
And I remember feeling like that was a
defining moment for me because it was
like I need to talk even more about
maybe not nostalgic things or things
that are outward that I see,
but things that are from me that
happened to me.
It's hard though because especially if
you're influenced by someone else and
you are,
you're a bit is influenced by their bed.
And even though you know it is,
you know,
you shouldn't probably do it because
everyone thinks that you kind of stole
it,
but it kills and that's the problem,
fucking crushed all you have at that.
And it's such a life pit.
It's just,
you know,
you could go up there with this one and
just fucking slam it in.
But really ethically it's almost like
you have to find out what's good about
that and cut it out and try to add it to
something that you create,
you know,
you,
you can be influenced by something and
you know,
and you're not even,
you're not even aware of it,
you know,
you never see what a lot of guys like
work together.
Like we saw that at the comedy store a
lot where like guys would work together
and guys would riff in the back parking
lot and then they would go on stage and
it was like,
it was like a battle over whose bid as
this who's been as this.
We're sitting out,
like Stan hope had this fucking guy that
was opening for him.
This guy was a Douche and he,
he would go onstage and they,
whenever they would would fucking riff,
stand hope and say a bunch of cool shit
and this guy would go on stage and do
stand ups.
Cool Shit.
It's just like,
fuck man.
Now I can't riff in front of you.
I can't just fuck around and come up
with it.
But then when you're still too are doing
it together and then you know,
you've got to figure out,
well who's is this?
What's going on here?
You know?
Or somebody like you,
you'll have an idea and original premise
and someone will add a tag to it and
then take your whole fucking thing.
And they added a tag.
Like,
no,
that's fucking.
It just came up with that
to this day like bobby and now because
I've known I since I was a kid,
13 years old,
bobby,
since I started,
bobby get Robert Kelly and us three.
Definitely.
I can hear it all the time.
Bobby does certain things.
I'm like,
oh,
that sounds like me or all three of us.
Because we started,
we spent so much fucking time together.
We formed our,
you know,
kind of comic,
uh,
cadences and all the tricks that you
learned that those were the two guys
that I can still watch and be like,
oh,
that's how we influenced each other.
Yeah.
I have one friend when I come up with an
idea,
I have to walk away.
I walk away and I say it in my head and
I write it down because I don't say it
in front of them because if I say in
front of them,
I'm pretty sure that it's eventually
going to on stage,
so I have to go away.
Am I fucking really do that?
Yeah.
But the worst is the one friend that you
have an idea and you start saying the
idea and they try to top it and they
start talking over you.
No,
no,
no.
You don't delicate.
It's coming out of nowhere.
It's coming out of manage base.
Let me say it.
Could you fucking imagine if.
Imagine if Oprah decided that she was
tying them on this book.
If you talk white now,
you're going to.
I'm going to miss.
I'm getting a gift right now from the
universe.
It's like ideas like crazy ideas
sometimes will come to you,
like fully formed,
but if you start talking and explaining
it to other people and then someone jams
in with their own shit,
it's like,
oh,
it's lost now.
Yes.
Or if they start trying to get to what
your getting to because they kind of get
a sense of it wrong,
wrong,
and you're like,
no,
that's not what I'm saying at all.
And then like,
fuck,
just lost all my momentum communications
data.
That's why we should all text each other
because that's just the whole time for
that.
Brian,
you're in your mind is your name from
now on the Internet is going to call you
Chris,
he,
Brian,
Brian.
At the end of the beginning of the show,
Dan showed up and Dan goes,
hey,
Chris.
And Brian was like,
I could call him Chris for like months
set
and I told them,
when you meet as many people as certain
people do,
literally you lose your,
your space in your memory bank for
people's lives because I don't see you
for a month.
You're fucking shit is gone from my
brain.
I know there you're that guy.
We could have hung out,
smoked a joint,
went to a movie.
I don't fucking remember you dude.
Right?
There's too many to remember.
Everything you remember Joe,
we,
uh,
we met and we hung out.
It was the galaxy theater and we all
stood on the curb like,
and you're like,
I don't fucking remember where this was.
I have a friend who's famous who likes
to fuck a bunch of different girls and
uh,
his whole,
I mean,
he's a complete pussy addict and he
doesn't think it's a big deal in these
girls aren't going to be attached to
them.
I'm like,
do you not understand?
I go,
you are,
you're in movies and people love you and
they see you all the time and they,
they,
they're,
they're attracted to you.
And you're meeting all these people,
millions and millions of them,
and it's not a big deal to you,
but to them it's like,
oh my God,
this is a big fucking giant movie.
And his penis inside my vagina.
It's like the greatest moment ever.
And you forgot her name already,
right?
It's literally one of the top three
things that they'll ever fucking one or
talk about what their close friends.
Yeah.
I tried to tell this dude the reason why
these girls go crazy is because they
think you're in love with them.
They think,
you know,
this is going to be like a love affair
now and you're just moving onto the next
check and you know,
you got to be careful that your single
girlfriend.
So I was with a trick for about five
years and about eight months ago.
So she was,
she was there for the big ride for most
of it.
Yeah.
Wow.
What would finally just drove the nail
everything a lot,
man.
Yeah.
Is she in the business?
In order was.
Yes,
but
I,
I went through a lot of Shit my folks
and then into my brother is four or five
years ever made surprised you're even
functioning,
you know,
because sometimes I am too men because
it really was a,
you know,
I lived to perform because I,
my folks were just the coolest fucking
people and uh,
they got but they got to see everything.
That's what I've come to the,
you know,
at the end of all the talking about it
and figuring it out.
It's like they got to see everything on
one.
Do you find it's hard to date chicks in
the business right now I'm just having
fun so I'm just Kinda like doing
whatever.
But I would not want to settle down with
a headshot.
That's it.
That's why I haven't no head shots
possible.
Yeah.
Year seven year period.
It was after seven years.
You haven't had a headshot in seven
years.
Okay.
You're good.
You're clear,
you're clear.
You're,
you've escaped the spell,
you know,
but there's,
real housewives of Calabasas,
all these crazy bitches.
They all wanted to be actresses.
Yeah,
man,
it's,
no,
I'm fucked up.
Okay.
But I've figured out how to deal with my
fucked up and make it work and be a,
you know,
a fairly healthy human being.
But I know that other people that are
fucked up,
like the odds are we're going to be able
to talk and hang out and be cool with
each other and make this work out and be
both.
Be Balanced.
It's very hard.
The odds are very,
very small that you're going to have
your shit together and we're going to
have a healthy relationship.
You know,
it's just like too many times over and
over and again you just deal with all
these crazy people and all this
psychosis involved in the auditioning
process breaks people's souls because
this getting this movie or getting this
television show or anything they're
auditioning for,
it could be the biggest fucking moment
in their life and they're freaking out
and they're pacing around the waiting
room and you get to see them go over
their lines like it's.
It makes.
I went for.
I read for us at comic six months ago.
I got nervous being in the room with all
these people that were nervous.
I was like,
I just want to get the fuck outta here.
Like this is a terrible feeling.
You know,
I've got money.
I don't have to worry about shit.
This.
It just seems like it'd be a fun job.
I'm looking at all these people like
this is like a big fucking thing to big
break and doing that every day over and
over again,
getting rejected,
needing that love,
getting rejected.
So close,
but nope.
Final three.
No,
no,
no.
And they're doing this for years and
years and this is already a person who's
psychologically unbalanced already a
person who.
The reason why they want to be a
performer in the first place is they
want to be loved because they weren't
loved as a child.
So there's this incredible horrible
imbalance and they just can't,
can't quite connect.
And then you start dating them and it's
like,
look man,
you're not on a.
A comfortable road like this isn't going
to be smooth and relaxed and everyone's
carefree.
This is going to be constant psychosis.
Do you think I'm good?
Do you think I'm fat?
Is this good?
Is What?
Am I a loser?
We read lines with me falling like that
though,
but I'm not dating our friends.
Yeah,
but they should still have that same
kind of fucking doing that five times a
day every day.
But they have success as comics.
That's the difference.
Guys like Joey and red either going to
auditions all the time,
but they're also killing it on stage all
the time.
They're also,
they're doing comedy all the time,
you know,
and Joe,
he's always getting acting gigs here and
there.
So it's like that in.
He's always getting,
you know,
car commercials here and there,
doing well.
It's the people that are not making the
connection and you know,
girls too,
you know,
if you're a girl,
man,
it's a natural feeling I think for a
girl to want some sort of male
companionship and protection for a woman
to be by herself.
Comes here from Omaha,
Nebraska or something.
She's going to be incredibly insecure.
Look at Cork in the middle of the ocean
by herself.
Anyway.
It doesn't have any friends committed to
this acting thing and then just
rejection,
and then their whole childhood thing
that dragged them there in the first
place.
Then you come along and your cage.
Let's go see a movie like you don't even
know what the fuck you're getting into.
Just opening up to him
door to hell.
My ex was one of the classic cases of
everything that I didn't know till after
the breakup.
Everything she always said she hated.
She came like literally every fucking
facet.
That's why they hate.
They hate.
They hate taxes.
What they're afraid of in themselves.
Right?
But it's tough because then people go,
you know what?
Like people that are further along in
this industry,
what?
I'm always like,
what's your gym?
What can you,
you know,
what?
What can I learn from you?
And they go,
yeah,
you don't want to be with a girl who's
in the industry,
but then you're like,
if somebody who isn't,
how do they really fucking understand
the bullshit that I then have to deal
with?
And so what's that middle ground?
Who is that girl in the middle?
Can find girls,
I've met girls from the business that
are really cool.
It's just really rare,
you know,
there's a lot of them that are just
right.
No one just like acting.
I am Kinda dating a girl now,
but after what I've been through,
you kind of more trepidatious because
you're like art,
if that's going to
throw that in there.
And trepidatious is a very rare word.
Thank you.
Know,
strong,
strong move.
It's,
there's a lot of people that do things
that you can't,
you can't find someone in the business,
but you can.
It's just rare.
You know,
you can't rule it out.
But as a rule,
if you're going to have an ethic,
it should be a no head shots policy.
Find some normal chick I haven't had and
buckshot policy.
I liked the way through the Gulf in the
middle.
That's Brian.
He's going to do something like that
just to make.
Oh Chris.
Chris.
So,
um,
now that you've,
you've done like how many specials for
cds,
couples?
Couple of specials when you do it now,
do you give yourself a specific amount
of time?
I do do a special and then say,
all right,
now I start fresh with all new material
and within like x amount of months.
I do a new one.
This is probably the first time in
awhile,
but I'm not putting a time limit on it.
I mean I used to,
it was like,
all right,
every,
it was like every other year and then
you're preparing during that time.
Right now is like,
I'm just,
I'm doing it for the first time at a
while.
Really just enjoying it is not a
machine.
It's not like I got a fucking top.
As I got to make money,
it's like I'm okay now.
I'm in a good spot.
My fans are happy,
I'm happy,
I'm balanced,
you know,
after some crazy years,
I'm just trying to enjoy fun.
I'm just trying enjoy it,
man.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because that's the thing that you guys.
It's like I had this moment.
I was like,
I had a good year when I hit where I'm
like,
this is her dream come true time.
And I really did enjoy it and then it
was like,
uh,
you know,
took care of my family and you know,
I had money and then a lot of stuff
happened.
So I,
you know,
a lot of stuff happened,
whether it was like internal from,
you know,
comedians or whether it was,
my folks being sick or all the shit dog
shitting and getting evicted.
It was like I didn't have time to just
be a regular person in process
everything.
And so that's what I've really done the
last couple years.
So go find it.
I find that it's drives me really crazy
when I come up with a bit and then I put
it on a special and then right after I
fucking film and I have a way better
tagline,
then I'm like,
I'll let this go too quick.
I should have worked on this part of the
process of developing materials.
You got to do a bit over and over and
over again until you find the rhythm of
it.
You find,
you know,
the natural order of the words and you
know,
never done.
It's never done,
man.
That's one of the great things about
those guys in Boston,
the untold story of why they were so
good as those guys had the same act
forever.
A lot of those guys unfortunately kept
the same act for years and years and
years and people actually grew to expect
it.
They would go see Steve Sweeney who was
fucking brilliant,
but it was the same.
Brilliant,
you know,
20 minutes that you had seen seven years
ago.
Right.
And they and they had it down and they
had their act and it was a fucking
machete and it would just slice through
the crowd.
It was just all the timing terminators.
Timing was just perfect,
you know,
the timing was just deadly.
There was so many of those guys then
too.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you come out with a bit and you don't
really develop it enough,
it's like you don't.
Maybe you didn't quite get it out the
perfect way.
You know,
people love new shit.
That's more important to them than
anything,
but you want to like,
God,
you want to make sure it's done.
Want to make sure it's really good.
I kinda was like a few years back it
fell into this routine of like,
you know,
maybe it's never done in.
Maybe it's always kind of evolving in
something else and that's okay.
Maybe it's just again,
more about who I am because I love guys
like even Johnny Carson growing up,
I didn't know what the fuck jody was
talking about half the time when I was a
kid,
but it was like this idea of,
Oh,
you're attracted to this,
this person,
and there's something glamorous about
standup where you can't go anywhere else
except for maybe what we're doing here
today without somebody impeding on it
and like editing it or some standards
and practice.
There's always somebody fucking with you
except comedies.
Glamorous.
Because you can say whatever it is you
want to say.
And that's one of the things that I love
about this podcast too,
is this is,
this is.
So look how easy this.
We'll just have a couch and a Webcam and
a fucking table in a laptop.
It's,
that's it.
That's all good.
A flashlight that you can fuck a
flashlight that you can fuck in some
microphones and no one can tell you what
to do and luck,
you know,
look,
it's not polished.
It's not.
We don't edit.
It was just fucking,
it's just a conversation.
It's a conversation every week.
You might like it,
we hope you do,
but no one's fucking with it.
And it becomes itself and you know,
other people digging their fingers in it
and
that I'll take this over any like any
even like for whatever reality t like
everything's so processed and so fucking
prepared,
right?
That why can't something be a little rag
tag,
a little messy in real and maybe a
little uncomfortable and really have an
amazing moment.
Well,
for you,
I think this is very important because I
think you're a very misunderstood guy
and the ability to express yourself for
long periods of time,
we'll get a chance for someone to see
your real personality as opposed to this
projected image that they have.
I get that.
You know,
so this is like an a great medium
because if you're doing like a fucking
tonight show set or something that
you're sitting on the couch,
you're talking for seven minutes.
To me it always feels like it's over.
That's it.
It's over.
It's like,
I don't even know who has I was.
I mean that I get it outright,
right?
You know that I just fucking force this
seven minutes.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
So nobody really.
I mean,
this is a fantastic opportunity that we
have today to do something like this.
This didn't exist for a performance of
other generations.
I mean the uh,
the ability to let people really know
who you are,
warts and all this is,
this is,
this is exactly who we are
in seeing comics and however many
entertainers like go from this to
getting that fame or fan base or
whatever it is without anybody in the
middle of it without managers and
agents.
And it's pretty incredible.
Man.
Bob.
Bob Burnham was Bo.
Bo Burnham Burnham,
he's like 18 or something as a really
young kid kind of open for me in New
Hampshire.
He's killing him everywhere.
He did a bunch of Shit on Youtube and
people love to songs on Youtube,
like comedic songs and all of a sudden
this kid is fucking packing place.
Right?
I mean,
it's incredible.
Just because of the Internet.
No one had that kid that was on Ellen,
that kid that sang that Papa Razzi Song.
The Lady Gaga Song was brilliant.
It was like a school talent festival or
something like that and this kid was
fucking brilliant.
It's amazing.
It's like you instantly,
you know,
can connect to people that just weren't
available before you before you had to
go through magazines.
But let's be devil's advocate for a
minute because how fucking quickly is
that kid fucked up now?
Oh,
he's dying because there's no fights
like he's out of that fucking play.
No tandem jump for him.
No fucking.
Let's do a thousand hours 11,
right?
Isn't he?
11 or something like that.
So he's 11.
That's the scary.
There will be a certain.
Chew them up,
spit them out.
Process with some of these people that
you know that make it through there.
It's like people who win the lottery,
most people who fucking play the lottery
or like,
you know,
fucking got nothing.
No.
You know,
and then you see that documentary on
Hbo.
You see lucky these fucking people that
had the water.
They're nowhere near prepared.
People who are already rich know how to
have money.
People who have nothing and they get
rich get fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Crazy Huh?
When I first bought my first development
deal,
my manager thought I had a gambling
problem and it was because I was buying
lobster like every night
eating like a king.
That will be nice.
I got a fat check and I just went off
like a rocket.
I was spending like 10 grand a month and
he was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I'm like,
I'm having fun pitch.
The first money I ever had in,
the dumbest thing I probably ever did
was I logged in and again this is when
the Internet,
like 56 k modem.
I logged into like a poker fucking
website and I,
and I'm like,
I'm going to play poker.
I'm pretty good at poker.
I lost five grand in my underwear and
about six minutes.
Wow.
Literally in the middle of the fucking
night.
I remember pushing my,
my ibm thinkpad away from me going,
I can never do this again.
Five grand like that.
Wow.
I love Internet gambling.
I love the idea.
I'm scared that it's fucking rig though.
Come on Joe.
Come on man.
I wonder because if you.
You can play guys on quake and they'd be
bots and they would never miss.
They would just destroy,
right?
Like literally 100.
No,
you'd never come close to them.
They would know where you were at all
times.
They know exactly the right weapon that
we use because they weren't really
playing.
It was just a computer simulation that
was playing perfectly.
Right.
These poker things.
Not only that,
but who's to say who's to say somebody
is in playing.
It has like a screen open of like our
best odds on hands and emitting else.
So it's like sure hackers that just
haven't been caught that are sitting
there like,
you know,
call of duty behind a wall and like
watching for sure.
We used to play chess online.
Then I'm like,
some fucking fag is gonna.
Have a chest fucking master thing opened
up and he knows 10 moves ahead already.
Doe
for chest,
you shouldn't even care.
Let them cheat.
Go ahead.
You know it's only gonna.
Make you better when you're playing
someone in chest.
He used to play the tough,
tough people.
Scrabble,
everyone's addicted to scrabble apps and
facebook,
scrabble.
Real so many websites.
You just sit there and you type in what
you have,
what,
what's been replaced,
and they'll tell you the best word you
know from the dictionaries points.
So play scrabble,
play old school,
just a table and some people sitting
around.
That's the only one that we live in.
A society where people feel victorious
when they figure out the best way to
cheat.
If I can figure out how to cheat out,
cheat you,
I'm fucking great.
I'm.
I'm more amazing than you at something.
It's fucking insane.
Is Pretty interesting.
But you think about the Russian mom.
How much money the Russian mom was made
by cheating,
by made,
by getting people's credit cards made by
hacking.
Things made by,
you know,
doing that.
It's like when you realize the actual
numbers involved,
like it's,
you know,
it's fuck,
it's a,
it's a branch of business.
I mean it literally is a branch of
business.
Do you think people's,
a branch of business ripping people off,
ripping off their websites,
hacking into their shit,
getting credit card numbers.
It's a branch of business.
I mean it's like this is sophisticated
Chen and this is being sophisticated
stuff being done on a high level.
Whenever you're going to have any sort
of a situation like that where there's
kind of an open door,
you know,
and there's programs you could run
programs in the background.
Think about how many goddamn viruses
there are,
you know,
I mean viruses and the loggers and fuck
man,
everything's going into the cloud,
man.
Everything's going.
It's sky bet,
dude.
It's happening.
Totally cool.
Bill is Sky Net,
right?
Google is.
I use it.
It's happening in email and I use the
chrome browser because that uses a whole
bunch of websites dedicated to that too.
Everything's.
That's Kinda weird man.
It's freaky when you think about like
pretty soon everything,
access to everything all the time
and computer power is exponentially
increasing.
So the,
the kind of programs that kind of things
that computers can do is going to
change.
Drag drastically over the next few
years.
But I watched a thing on dateline the
other night.
It was about a woman who fell for the
scam of like a,
you know,
contact us.
There's a million dollars in a bank
account and I couldn't believe it.
It was like this woman was like,
Oh,
I'm a $300,000
down because they keep writing me saying
we need more money to get the money out.
And I get those all time.
Time.
You people are crazy.
You have write them back.
Sometimes I'll read them back just for
the hell of it to be like a whole email
folders says scams and it's just
conversations that I have with fucking
terrorists.
That's you gotta.
You gotTa Post that Shit.
That's fucking weird to me.
I get,
I get like I get at least one a day.
These one,
one guy a day.
Good evening,
sir,
that I represent the Bank of new castle
and we right now have you know a
situation.
You don't know your name but they know
dear sir or Ma'am and you're like,
ah,
this you could possibly help me.
There's $3,
million dollars in cash here.
I'm looking for someone who can come up
with a small deposit to get out the,
you know the box.
Like that's it.
Fuck man.
But a lot of people get fooled by those
Nigerians.
Apparently.
It's a get for those key where they
think it's facebook and you type in your
username every day is a new person on
facebook or something like that.
Yeah,
phishing sites or big man,
you know,
look,
people are fucking crafty.
You gave somebody my phone number
member,
some dude you thought was really cliffy
be.
Oh,
that's right.
I started getting phone calls.
I'm like,
fuck bro.
Shit.
It's like,
I thought it was a real cliff.
He was a good trick to.
It was not a good address.
Well,
I mean for if it tricked me,
you know it's a little bit better.
It was new and lazy.
Myspace account became a fan boy.
Everything you were a fan boy and he
didn't pay attention to the actual
address.
Whatever they cloned his weapon.
God.
God,
At least it ain't twitter.
My phone number.
I did twitter,
my phone number or DM to somebody.
Yeah,
fucked up.
But I kept it as a fan line.
It's fascinating.
I'll just turn it on in the middle of
nowhere and start answering calls.
Joe Rogan.
Fan Line.
Start talking to people.
That's why you got to get st man.
Yeah.
It sounds like the coolest Shit,
man.
That APP is great,
I will get.
Get it can ring your phone.
They never know your phone number.
You go live.
I do a thing.
I go live.
You hit a button,
sends it to everybody and then they can
just call like a radio station like
this.
Rolling.
Are they located in San Francisco?
Is the headquarters located in San
Francisco?
Yeah,
I believe so,
yeah,
because I met someone who was trying to
get me to do that years ago.
I would.
Of course I blew it off then.
You should do it.
Yeah.
No,
I'm on it.
What other things?
What other things do you do for
promotion?
How many different things are you
involved in?
Just a few.
One of yourself.
Human.
I'd do the same now.
Obviously facebook,
uh,
you know,
the twitter stuff,
not,
not a lot,
man.
Those are like the,
those I don't do for.
I don't know what foursquare is.
Why I hate that shit.
Why would you want it to be the stalker?
What does that.
Hey,
I'm at applebee's.
Here's the exact location I am here.
Oh,
that's not going to happen.
What is that?
My location stuff.
Like why?
Why would you want to do that?
There's an app on your ipad where you
could just sit here and put your address
in.
It would show you all your neighbors who
have twittered or at least who have
said,
yes,
you can use my patients in twitter.
You can see who's in your neighborhood
is twittering.
Ridiculous.
Yeah,
that's creepy.
There's like four.
I just read,
there's like 45 apps right now in the
APP store that have coded it so that
people can log in and get your contacts
list.
Really?
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
There's a year old kid put up handy like
two weeks ago.
Right?
Right.
And it was loud.
Tethering,
tethering.
40th five.
That's how many.
They admit there's like 45.
Then I'll let you know.
What's crazy is what's even worse is
android.
When an android there was so many bad
rogue apps,
like I downloaded a weather app and it
was just supposed to give me the weather
and it was like,
this is going to take your contact list.
You know how it gives you the warnings
of all of the things.
That was like five different things.
I was like,
why?
This is a weather app.
Why is it named my contacts?
This is how much of a fucking scoundrel
I am right now.
When you're single.
Again,
I had a girl call me randomly and
because I know my numbers out there
sometimes when people can,
you know,
people do post shit.
It's like you change your number,
what's 12?
So middle of the night I'm like,
hello,
you know,
giggling and is this Dane?
And I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
What's up?
Where did you get this number?
Oh my God.
And then finally she sounded so hot that
I was like,
where are you guys ready?
age,
sex,
location.
How old are you guys?
We're like,
Oh,
we're 20 zero.
He goes in La,
what's up?
Send a picture.
So.
So they sent a picture.
You're single again.
You're like,
no,
laws that govern me.
Fucking take full advantage of that.
That's crazy magic trick you have.
It doesn't feel like a crazy magic trick
as long as you recognize it's a magic
trick.
The real problems with dudes who have
the magic trick.
Don't think it's a trick.
I think I am this fucking special.
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
that's an easy soup to start drinking.
No,
I never forget and go a guy that
couldn't fuck get it done.
I had no gay.
I had no fucking approach.
So yeah,
I'm constantly reminded.
Strange thing when people are under the
spell,
you know when they're looking at someone
famous and you see that their,
their heart's beating fast and their
hands are shaking.
Wow.
Just just because they've seen your
image broadcast somewhere or they
thought you did something that they
enjoy it.
Be With Steve Matrix.
Steve Martin.
That's how it would be.
Steve Martin says,
be like painfully matrix.
They just want to believe that stakes.
Real fuck it.
I don't care if it's that real.
Still to this day.
I'll go back and listen to.
Let's get small.
Fuck.
You know,
especially for them maybe when was,
it was at like 78 or something like that
right before the jerk.
Right.
Wasn't that like right before the jerk?
Yep.
Fuck man.
And he told me I was asking her about
the jerk because as much as I could,
I was like you.
Once he warmed up,
I was like,
tell me a little about the jerk.
And He,
you know,
he was like,
I was just driving to the Gig everyday
with Carl Reiner and we're like,
is this funny?
Is this funny?
They were just doing more comics do and
then get to set and make it work.
Wow.
Yeah.
They were like,
we had no clue what we were doing or how
big that was going to be.
I want to know what happened with them
because there was definitely a point in
his time kind of after planes,
trains and automobiles around Grand
Canyon Times or it seemed like he just
stopped playing Steve Martin and started
acting like a old man or something like
no more crazy.
He was forcing the crazy feeling that a
lot of comics who don't want to be like,
you got to take me serious.
A lot of comics go through that phase
where it's like I'm a serious human
being stopped smoking weed.
That weird thing.
Where were
comics want to be taken seriously?
And they start like making points on
stage that aren't funny.
Yeah.
I worked with this comic once.
I'm not going to say his name,
but he's a political guy,
pretty famous guy,
and he did this line and then he said
that usually gets an applause break and
it wasn't.
It wasn't even remotely funny.
It was some silly fucking Democrat
versus Republican point that should be
obvious to anybody who's paying
attention and it was just like,
wow,
like you're going for that.
Like they,
they lose this perspective and all of a
sudden they start thinking that they're
like this voice over
and people need to hear like,
come on
man,
you're supposed to just be funny.
Right?
If you don't have anything funny to say
about a subject or if it's not setting
up something funny later.
No,
I understand.
If you want to get a point across or
give a perspective that may not be
funny,
but it gives us your point of view.
So I understand what you're talking
about when you say some funny shit
later,
but if you start preaching,
that's a fucking tricky
thing,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
that's not many guys can do it though a
lot,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
and it seemed like there was like a
phase,
not as much now,
but a few years ago where everybody was
trying to do that.
You know,
where everybody was like,
this is the point in my career.
I'm going to dim the lights and do bill
Maher real talk,
right?
It's like,
no,
I'm there.
I'm there for fucking sucks man.
I'm there to make you laugh your ass
off.
I'm there to make you escape for a
little bit.
There's a lot of fucking guys that do
it,
you know,
a thousand times better than me,
but I figured out how to do it my way to
where I can entertain you and we can all
forget about the real hardcore shit for
a little bit.
That's all I'm supposed to do.
Really.
I can do some flicks if I can produce
some TV stuff.
Great.
I love comedy.
That doesn't have to mean shit like Joey
Diaz,
one of my favorite guys to watch ever
because everything is okay.
My ass and my boss,
my Boston to everything ended up ending
your joke.
It ended up off your ass.
Create like really deep thinkers and I
appreciate people with really
fascinating point of view,
but for the most part,
a lot of that stuff is not funny.
A lot of that stuff really.
It's almost,
you're disrespecting certain topics by
doing them onstage.
I mean,
you can kinda like brush on it and like
Kinda like you dabble in it,
but if it's a really fascinating
subject,
it's something that needs to be
explored.
It's going to share a funny but just
just for flat out funny.
Like for me,
I like stupid shit.
I look like a Joey Diaz type guy.
That's the kind of Shit I laugh at.
I wanna,
you know,
I wanna I wanna laugh at someone.
I mean I love good writing and
everything like that,
but I love just as much.
You know,
Joey Diaz,
he's got this joke about transvestites.
He goes,
I love transvestites.
They Cook,
they clean.
You can beat on them.
Every once in a while the cops come,
who's going to believe me or some dude
with a wig and a black guy that's like
just bang,
Bang,
Bang.
I mean it's just laughing.
That's fucking tremendous job.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like that's my,
that's the kind of shit that will make
me clap and laugh and then hours later
it'll be at the diner eating,
clapping and laughing.
You know,
that's,
that's my favorite kind of comedy.
I like just stupid shit.
That's why I like old Steve Martin.
Exactly old.
Steve Martin was awesome.
Who are your favorite comics like today?
That work today?
I just watched Berg and on letterman.
I think billy's just like,
he's one of the funniest guys out there
and I think he,
you know,
he's like a,
he's an architect man.
He gets out there and he fucking figures
out and he's just funny.
It's just about fucking being funny and
he's not going to use his power to do
that.
Try to get funny cat man.
It's all pure.
I like to watch chapelle before,
you know,
he kind of disappeared,
you know?
I always appreciated watching dave get
up the guy who's like on the same level
level as him,
like fame wise.
Does it freak you out that he doesn't
fucking perform and these big places,
does it freak you out that like why
don't you like,
let people know where you're going to
be?
Man,
why don't you do more shows?
Like I'm just one of the best ever.
One of the best ever right now.
It's so rare.
I don't know,
Dave personally.
It's all like,
I don't have insight,
but just from what I hear,
you know,
he's just,
he's,
he's got some stuff to work out,
you know,
so maybe he's just not a place where he
can face that head on.
I know I'm putting it together.
I know what you're talking about.
And I heard that crazy story about the
whatever the hell happened on the
airplane right where they had to land
somewhere in the pilot.
I thought that he was a hazard to the
flight.
So they landed early.
Yeah,
that's extreme.
That's extreme stuff.
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck is going on,
but I met him.
I did.
I mean the comedy clubs in New York and
I did this show twice and he's just
always been a cool dude,
but I never got to know him deep.
Yeah.
I don't think he's like that though.
I don't think a lot of people know him
personally.
He's Kinda,
you know,
living in fucking Utah or somewhere and
just.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's strange,
Huh?
Yeah.
But you know,
that's one of the things that I said
also that I think people really love
about him is the fact that he is kind of
reclusive.
He is kind of like the reluctant star
and one of the things that people will
like go after use like the,
you already have attention.
So they're like,
why is this fucking guy I want more
attention,
you know,
fuck fucking attention to or look at
this attention to or show your mouth
attention,
whore,
you know,
it's like that's what it is.
Like people think that like when you
promote,
if you're self promoting that somehow or
another,
you know,
you're doing something to them.
Sure.
You know,
do you get stop fucking spamming me
any,
any level of success.
And what I've learned having you know,
against slow but short trajectory is
like there's always more people that
don't like what you do,
them corn like what you do and that's
it.
And you just attract more,
more of people that like you more don't
like you will be attracted to you and
tell you.
Of course.
I'm totally hypocritical.
I hated a serious man and I went on
twitter and I'm like,
seriously fucking suck.
You know,
if somebody could have seen me perform
and you know,
did the same thing,
but that's okay though.
You got to realize that,
you know,
there's going to people,
there's a lot of music that I fucking
love and you know,
if you know,
Mrs Rogan gets in the car with me.
She was like,
what the fuck are you listening?
And I'm like,
this is,
I was made for loving you.
Okay.
You don't know this.
You don't know this fucking song.
You know somebody likes your pelvis.
I mean,
regardless of what he's dealing with,
there's so many.
When Steve Martin did arenas,
Steve Martin was doing also,
he wasn't doing like,
when people say like arenas today,
yeah,
I'm doing maybe 20,000
people.
That dude was doing fucking 60,000
people in an arena where he was
partitioned with no screens,
nothing man.
Mike white suit dot on the other side of
the place.
So you understand.
But with me,
it's like I have the most amazing,
like the guy that comes out,
my road guy,
Al Dot Lee.
He did Zeplin,
he did Elvis.
He's got all the gadgets.
We put screens.
We make you feel like you're in your
living room.
I go in the middle,
not because I want to be a gladiator
because it's four theaters at any point.
It's easier to be close to people from
the middle.
It wasn't like a thing where it was
like,
yeah,
by being in the middle,
I'm the.
I'm the rockstars.
No,
it was like I need to be as close to
people in these big shows as positive.
Only done one theater in the round show
ever.
Maybe to.
Was it a in Cape Cod?
No,
I don't think it turned.
Remember that rally?
Yeah.
What was that one?
A minute where it would like the whole
stage.
Was that feeling when it turned?
I think it was feminine.
It was phoenix.
Yeah.
I did something and it always weirded me
out that people are behind me,
you know,
fucking strange.
I'm performing and I'm not looking at
these people behind me
that.
Yeah,
I couldn't get past that.
That was freaking me out,
but what's really is smarter,
right?
More,
more dynamic.
It's a three dimensional approach as
opposed to standing in this one plane
facing this one way every time.
Yeah.
When,
when people are behind you too,
and I always keep a little light on
everybody.
There's a constant flow of energy by
seeing other people and feel it's just.
There's something unique about being in
the middle,
like they're seeing people,
not just you,
not just seeing a stage,
a few.
They're seeing people watching you and
that is an additive.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Absolutely.
It's an interesting way to look at it.
Yeah.
Like everybody's like,
Whoa,
we're on this together.
If you're just talking about audit
energy level,
if you wanted to talk about that.
Like for me it's like what you put out
there and it doesn't dissipate the way I
feel it does when you're just launching
an APP.
Them like your mental look at me when
they feel like they're part of it,
they're connected to it.
It's a different kind of comedy man.
It's a different show and the screens.
Look,
I got all four,
so even when my back's to you,
there's never a seat.
Even if
you're up top,
you're looking directly out at a,
at a,
at a screen.
So we figured out how to make it work.
That's pretty fucking bad.
Yeah.
It's got to be really strange.
Do shows for that many people.
What is it like to do a show for 20?
I think the most
come out and do it man.
Next time I do a Gig,
come out and do a,
you know,
come out and open.
I'm telling Ya know,
I'm serious man.
I always have people,
you know,
people have never done those silos shows
on the last door.
I just feel like to come out,
come out and uh,
it was great man and everybody thinks
it's not going to work for me there.
It's like no.
First of all,
my fans are comedy fans.
They're not the kind of people that get
like,
oh,
we're just waiting for.
They love comedy.
Most of my fans.
And you never want to go back once
you've done big shows like that in the
round man.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I promise.
Very bizarre.
Yeah,
I know.
You dig it,
man.
You dig it.
I have a shiny bald spot in the back of
my hand.
I need powder you up,
joe telling you right now.
I got all that shit.
Are you kidding me?
I'm thinking no.
Had had 20,000
people.
What is the biggest crowd you've ever
performed?
Gator growl data grounds.
Forty 8,000
in Florida.
Yeah,
Gainesville.
Damn.
Forty 8,000.
Holy Shit.
That was pretty cool.
What the fuck was that like?
That first laugh was like,
it came across the field.
That's insane.
But I would never want to do that size
in that like a stadium.
If I could do that again doing it arena.
It's compact.
Everybody's right on you.
And um,
keeps you imagine eating shit on stage
in front of 48,000.
Imagine bombing.
Can you imagine hitting a job?
Especially if you did a controversial
choke and they didn't like it and they
turn on you 48,000
and maybe you got to still do another 40
minutes.
You better make sure that's what
interests me.
I made sure my fans are showing up for
this.
I'm not setting myself up for that.
Kind of still look back and remember the
first time you ever bombed?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
A bunch of them I just wrote.
It's called New York.
I just,
I just wrote a chapter in this book.
I'm writing all on the very first time I
ever bombed,
which is a horrible,
terrible disaster that I,
I'll never forget cause it was the first
time I ever bombed while I was getting
paid.
Oh Shit.
That's a big difference.
Balmy at open mic nights.
Everybody's bombing,
you know,
it's like there's like five people are
gonna eat shit onstage and you're only
up there for five minutes,
but once you do a paid.
And I was middling.
I shouldn't have been middling.
I really didn't have the time.
And the guy went on before me fucking
crushed.
And uh,
there was this chick that I had seen the
last time I was there and she was super
hot.
I fucked her and she was in the front
row and she brought her friends and her
friends look and they were going to sit
in the front row when I went on stage,
so I was panicking.
I was like,
they're going to be like right in front
of me.
I was only like a year and accommodate a
year and a half post and this guy went
up who was the MC was way better than
me.
He was.
He was already better than me and I was
like,
I conned this fucking book to making me
a middle.
I was like,
it's just a cocky dude.
I can be.
I can middle.
Come on,
So he lets me move on.
This guy goes on stage and does and he
stopped doing comedy.
It's really too bad.
He's a natural.
I don't remember his name unfortunately,
but he fucking killed and then I went
him an eight just drive bricks of shit
with no water for 20 minutes.
It was the most embarrassing feeling
I've ever had in my life.
I couldn't believe how unbearable and
her and her friends were like looking at
each other and her friends would lean
over and say something like,
oh no,
and then I could hear crickets and I'm
trying to be like extra loud because I'm
trying to like be trying to bring it
back to my side.
So like you like forced the punchlines
and the timing is all even worse.
And my only experience with being
nervous before,
my only experience with pressure had
been fighting.
So when you know fighting and
tournaments,
you know,
if you're nervous,
you just turned inward and you say,
this isn't mine,
I want to do this,
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to do is I'm going to fucking
explode.
I'm just going to go terrified.
But you just get psyched up to go.
Which is the worst thing you could ever
do on stage to be nervous and aggressive
and fucking and all introspective and
turned into yourself and to get faculty
to take them are just going to call.
It was the worst mindset ever for
comedy.
That's called being Carlos Mitzia.
Turn it in.
I'm going to explode
the most.
I had a shoe.
Did you ever do shows about microphones?
Oh yeah.
Yup.
Parties ever do a Bachelor party?
I did,
yeah.
I used to do like a colleges around
Boston where they'd hire me and I'd be
like,
I'd be standing on a pool table in the
cafeteria.
Standing on a cliff.
Cheerio chair.
A table?
Yeah.
Rickety table.
Like I couldn't move that was there.
Their stage.
I did a place in in Florida called the
rathskeller.
They hired me to come down and it was
like one of my first road gigs and it
was the thing where it's like there's
food being served during the tvs are on
edge,
like all that shit where it's like the
whole everything is happening and I'm
doing standup and like somebody threw a
hot dog at me like five minutes into an
hour.
Those gigs are so important.
Man.
All those shit gigs at Boston comedy
used to book and all those little weird
fucking places in New Hampshire.
You would drive an hour and a half up to
New Hampshire and do some weird bar with
a tinny sound system.
Those are so good though.
When you look back at it now,
like how important were those like for
developing your ability to focus on
stage and kill and cut the fat out of
your act and
driving home from domain.
Once I got a gig up there and it was the
first time that there were a few years
and I drove home and I'm like,
all right,
this,
this matters.
Even though it was horrible,
I was like,
this matters it this.
Someday I will look back on tonight.
Know that like I learned fucking
something here.
Oh man,
but it was back.
Yeah.
You do those gigs and you just like,
wow.
Like this is.
This doesn't even feel like show
business.
It feels like I did a thing with this
guy,
Scott puppet curie.
He used to book the Mattapoisett in this
little tiny shithole,
but it was a great little room where I
got to see Teddy Burger on.
By the way,
who was a fucking genius?
Yes.
One of the best comics ever.
One of the best comics ever had one of
the best tonight show sets of all time.
Did you ever see us tonight?
Show sense.
It's fucking genius.
Another guy.
Were you.
How could this guy not be in everybody's
mind as one of the greatest comics app
and this Guy Scott peppertree booked a
gig for.
He and I on block island and block
island was an island outside of Rhode
Island I think,
and there's nothing there.
It's just drunk,
retarded fishermen and they are dumb as
fuck and they're so drunk.
They are all of them.
There's maybe 20 people in the room.
All of them are so drunk.
They can't even keep their eyes open.
Their mouths are slides in here and we
have to do comedy for them and Scott
gets up and starts shitting all over
them and he was not really.
He hadn't been doing comedy that long
then really probably shouldn't have been
on stage in this sort of situation
anyway.
And I went on after him and they had
already turned their backs to the comedy
show.
Like half of them.
They turned their backs and just started
a conversation and we had to stay in a
wasn't.
It wasn't in a hotel room.
It was in a supply room.
They have two cots in a supply room with
no shower and there was a bathroom,
you know,
we could take like,
a,
a bath,
bath and you know,
we stayed in this little fucking supply
room until we could catch the boat back
then
stay.
Oh Man,
I did.
So many of those little more colleges
were psyched.
I got a Gig.
I know at the time.
Yeah.
At the time you're like,
all right,
I get a Gig.
I'm making 50 bucks or whatever it was.
But oh man.
Brutal.
Bangor,
Maine.
I did a bunch up there.
Yeah,
I did a bunch for normally foe.
He had all these gigs in western
Massachusetts were out there where you
had to drive 40 miles an hour because
deer would jump in front of your fucking
car every five minutes.
You had to be careful that you didn't
die.
Like you get to these certain gates,
your shows and especially Western mass
near Amherst.
I remember there was a lot of two lane
roads where you would see dead deer all
over the place.
Fucking wreck cars.
I nailed one one night.
Digital.
Yeah.
Yeah,
just as just as ass had just gotten past
me and I did the thing where I gunned
it.
I'm like,
I want her to swerve,
but the voice was like,
come in and I fucking hit him and I
watched him spin off into the woods.
Did you
die from that?
A lot of people have died from hitting.
Like especially if you hit a fucking
moose.
If you hit a moose,
you,
you might be dead to the windshield and
crush your fucking spine.
Yeah,
right.
I had a dream that might go.
Birth guy I work with in the UFC.
Got Killed by a grizzly bear and it was
a very graphic movie in my head,
like a very graphic dream where it was
very realistic and I woke up,
like literally woke up like Whoa.
Like he was with his wife and his kids
and they were in a river and I'll
fucking grizzly bear came running
through the bank of the river,
jumped into the water and just fucked
him up in front of everybody.
She says,
yeah,
very strange.
Microburst if you listen to but don't go
in the river,
stay the fuck away future of,
uh,
that's like 30 years from now,
that's what fucking sports going to be.
It's got to be literally be like a guy
mixed martial arts verse,
some kind of Hybrid DNA government
experiments like half fucking cougar.
The only reason why there's not
sword fights on TV is because no one's
put sword fights on TV.
If they were,
people would love to watch that.
Two guys with Samurai swords trying to
hack each other's fucking head.
So I think we're going to produce our
very first show together.
I love it.
Versus the Christians.
I mean those people weren't much
different than us today.
You know what I mean?
How is that different than ghetto
gaggers.com?
How is that different than some of the
shit that you watch?
Like those Mexican drug dealers cutting
that guy's head off with a small knife.
Have you seen that video?
Fuck you see the suicide jump off off
the fucking Uber has had.
It blows up like a coconut undergoes
awful.
You can't unsee that stuff,
but you know that it's out there.
You know when you see someone really
fucking shifty when you go to seven
slash 11,
you should know this guy might pull out
a gun,
might commit suicide.
The fuck knows.
I mean,
you know,
you've seen so much fucked up shit on
the Internet.
I think to a certain extent it
influences people's behavior and it
makes people a little bit more fucked up
than maybe they could be because they
have all this stuff.
They have access to this,
but on the other side you should be more
aware of what is possible.
You might be a good person who is always
around nice people.
You're a mormon or something,
and so you think everybody's a mellow
and predictable and then all of a sudden
you're around some fucking gang banger
and you don't know what the fuck this
is.
You don't know what the rules are.
You don't know what's what game he's
playing.
Yeah,
and you know what?
Most people don't realize in those
situations,
you have no true.
You better fight your fucking ass off
when you see people going along with it.
That's when you're like,
oh,
this is going to be bad.
I saw God get knocked out.
He was,
uh,
he looked like he just,
they just did these thugs.
Just found him coming out of a um,
it looked like a convenience store.
They knocked him out,
knocked him out,
unconscious.
The Guy Falls,
bangs his head off the concrete,
out cold,
arms are stiff and the dude starts
pissing on his face.
He pulls a Dick and piss on it.
Just decided to knock this guy out of
nowhere.
Like you need to know that there's
people like that out there,
but that's real shit.
I mean,
you going to be paranoid and fucking,
you know,
and start dwelling on it and get all
second amendment right.
How do you get to know that person is
they have a facebook page,
Hey,
I'm been knocking people out.
My wrap up is my tag tags.
I piss on you just,
it was hard to watch it on twitter.
It was hard to watch because you see the
half conscious and the pisses him and
his face and just moving like that could
be you.
It could be anybody,
anybody knew,
somebody decides to steal on.
You're in the wrong place,
the wrong time,
and some guy who you never saw common
decides to punch you in the face and
Piss on your unconscious body.
And on that note,
ladies and gentlemen,
at the end of this fucking podcast,
I'm,
I'm glad you came over to again,
we're sponsored by the fleshlight
fleshlight.com.
You know,
you and I have had our differences over
the year,
but,
um,
I always,
uh,
respected your ability to market
yourself.
And I always respected your ambition.
And I think sometimes when people are
ambitious,
things don't necessarily work out the
way they should be.
But I know you're a good dude and I know
that you,
uh,
you're always working on your act.
I see it all the time.
I know you're doing the right things and
I hear your interviews and I know you're
in a good place with your mind and I
think that's important,
man.
And,
uh,
I think it's also important that,
you know,
at a certain stage in your life,
you have to recognize when you've had
differences with somebody and you know,
it's not that I don't like you as a
person,
you know,
just differences and I'm glad that we
put all that shit past and
oh man,
that means the world here in that you
get a lot of integrity and I've,
I've always had a lot of respect for
her,
which is part of the reason that there
was for me on my side when anybody ever
came to me with anything.
It was like I have really nothing to say
about it and I hope that time will just,
uh,
eventually figure that out.
So I appreciate that.
Good to be here on your show.
We'll do it again.
Yeah,
dude,
for sure.
For sure.
And I think,
you know,
stuff like this,
like I said,
is perfect for a guy like you to.
So people really get a chance to see who
you really are.
True.
No bullshit.
No.
And I don't think anybody who was thrust
into your condition is going to come out
of it without some scrapes.
I mean you,
you thrust yourself into like really
like a,
a,
a stratosphere like that.
Very few human beings ever have to
navigate how many Lohan you did it.
Yeah.
You did it over a very short period of
time.
So I think people need to respect that.
I think you did an awesome job.
Thanks.
I've got through it and you're doing all
the right shit.
And I enjoyed how you did that isolated
incident.
I was telling people I love how you did
it all in one take and all like with one
camera.
Like right on the stand.
You could tell there was no edits to it.
I was like,
that was really cool.
That was like a cool creative choice,
you know?
I think you're doing some awesome stuff.
Thanks.
Thank you.
I'm a good work.
Keep a good luck with your writing
because to get that program by the way.
Yeah,
right.
Room folks who are.
I'm into it.
I think it only works for the Mac,
but I know that there's a version of it
for the PC as well that does the exact
same thing and it's just for all you
creative types who are easily distracted
and uh,
if you're also easily distracted and you
have a hard time writing pickup.
This book called the war of art.
I think it's Steven Pressfield is a guy
wrote,
you ever heard of it?
No,
fucking war of art.
I bought a bunch of them and I give them
out to people.
Um,
yeah,
I think I might have one.
I'll give one to you.
It's an amazing book and it's all about
how you can overcome resistance and like
focus your mind for writing.
Really,
really brilliant book.
Everybody does it the book,
but he was,
you know,
he was talking,
he talks about it in the book.
I mean,
here's a guy who really didn't become
successful as a writer until he was in
his forties and he recognizes his own
errors and what his own like bad
patterns of thought and he,
he sort of addresses all of them that
all creative type stuff.
And this thing.
Cool.
Anyway,
ladies and gentlemen,
a twitter.com/Dane
Cook twitter.com/red
band.
I'm Joe Rogan.
Thanks for tuning in you guys.
And uh,
we'll,
we'll see you next week.
Love you bitches.